This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the early days of Soviet cinema, a filmmaker conducted an experiment that would change our understanding of the human mind. Lev Kulishav showed an audience a short film featuring a famous actor. The footage of the actor was always the same, a single, unmoving, and entirely neutral expression. But the filmmaker intercut the shot with three different images. A bowl of hot soup, a child in a coffee. and a woman reclining on a sofa. Even though the actor's face never changed,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在苏联电影的早期，一位电影制作人进行了一项实验，这项实验改变了我们对人类思维的理解。列夫·库里肖夫向观众展示了一部短片，片中有一位著名演员。演员的镜头始终如一，是一个单一、静止且完全中性的表情。但这位电影制作人将这个镜头与三个不同的画面剪辑在一起：一碗热汤、一个孩子和一口棺材，以及一个躺在沙发上的女人。尽管演员的脸从未改变，
the audience was mesmerized by his performance. When paired with the soup, they saw a man gripped by hunger. When paired with a coffin, they saw our face transformed by grief. They didn't see a sequence of unrelated pictures. They saw an integrated story. The human brain is wired to make connections like this. We want to see the frames as part of a narrative, and so we invent the connective tissue. We turn frame one and an unrelated frame two into a cohesive story.
观众却被他的表演深深吸引。当与汤搭配时，他们看到的是一个被饥饿折磨的男人。当与棺材搭配时，他们看到的是一张因悲伤而扭曲的脸。他们看到的不是一系列不相关的图片，而是一个完整的故事。人类的大脑天生就会建立这样的联系。我们希望将这些画面视为叙事的一部分，因此我们发明了连接组织。我们将第一帧画面和不相关的第二帧画面变成了一个连贯的故事。
This psychological tendency also shapes how we see our own lives. We are the editors of our own personal documentaries, constantly splicing together random chaotic events into a narrative. Depending on our personalities and temperaments, our documentaries might be comedies or trussing. They might be gripping tales or boring stories where nothing much happens. But all of this raises a question. If we are the ones sitting in the editing room, are we making the best use of the footage?
这种心理倾向也塑造了我们看待自己生活的方式。我们是自己个人纪录片的剪辑师，不断地将随机、混乱的事件拼接成叙事。根据我们的个性和气质，我们的纪录片可能是喜剧，也可能是悲剧。它们可能是扣人心弦的故事，也可能是平淡无奇、没什么大事发生的琐事。但这一切都提出了一个问题：如果我们是坐在剪辑室里的人，我们是否在最有效地利用这些素材？
Are we choosing to tell the right stories? This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, the tales we tell about our lives and why some stories turn out to be better for us than others. When we turn on the TV or read a novel or buy a ticket to a movie, we're in search of a good story. A narrative that will capture our imagination, transport us to a different world, offer a satisfying resolution. The best stories create this magic. How do they do this? At Boston College, Benjamin Rogers studies how narratives generate meaning and significance in our minds and the implications of the story.
我们是否选择了讲述正确的故事？本周在《隐藏的大脑》以及《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套故事中，我们将探讨关于我们生活的叙事，以及为什么有些故事对我们来说比其他故事更好。当我们打开电视、阅读小说或购买电影票时，我们都在寻找一个好故事。一个能抓住我们想象力、将我们带入另一个世界、提供令人满意的结局的叙事。最好的故事创造了这种魔力。他们是如何做到的？在波士顿学院，本杰明·罗杰斯研究叙事如何在我们的头脑中产生意义和重要性，以及这些故事的影响。
we tell about our own lives. Ben Rogers, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, Shankar. It's great to be here. Ben, I understand that starting when you were a teenager, you've been interested in stories. In the books that you've read about the craft, especially when it comes to the craft of filmmaking, you learn that there was one storytelling framework
我们讲述关于自己生活的故事。本·罗杰斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。你好，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。本，我了解到从你十几岁起，你就对故事很感兴趣。在你读过的关于创作的书籍中，特别是在电影制作的工艺方面，你了解到有一种讲故事的框架，
that audiences find especially compelling. Now, this framework shows up in ancient literature and modern tales. I'm wondering if we can start with a story like Harry Potter. How does the Harry Potter story follow the storytelling framework? Sure, yeah. So it starts off with Harry at the time that you meet him. He's an orphan boy.
观众觉得特别引人入胜。现在，这个框架出现在古代文学和现代故事中。我想知道我们是否可以从像《哈利·波特》这样的故事开始。哈利·波特的故事是如何遵循这个讲故事框架的？当然，可以。故事开始时，你见到哈利的时候，他是一个孤儿。
He's living with his uncle, an aunt and cousin, but he's just kind of put down upon, doesn't have anything special about him. But then mysterious things keep happening, and then he ends up having a moment of shift. And that's when a series of wizards and wizard-adjacent people tell him that he's actually, unbeknownst to him,
他和他的叔叔、姨妈和表弟住在一起，但他只是那种被轻视的人，身上没有什么特别之处。但随后神秘的事情不断发生，他最终经历了一个转变的时刻。那时，一系列巫师和与巫师相关的人告诉他，他实际上在不知不觉中，
a wizard and he needs to go off to Hogwarts a school to learn how to craft magic and to take up the mantle by his parents that he didn't know a lot about. And so over the course of the first story and over the series, he learns, he faces a series of challenges in terms of facing monsters and people who want to hurt him and hurt his friends. But he learns magic and he ends up transformed and really embracing the idea that he's there to help others and become someone who can stand up to fight for the little guy. And this is one of those stories that, both within an individual novel or a movie,
是一个巫师，他需要去霍格沃茨学校学习如何施展魔法，并承担起他父母留下的重任，而他对此知之甚少。因此，在第一个故事和整个系列的过程中，他学习并面对了一系列挑战，包括面对怪物和那些想要伤害他及他朋友的人。但他学会了魔法，最终发生了蜕变，真正拥抱了帮助他人、成为能够挺身而出为弱者而战的人的理念。这就是那些故事之一，无论是在单本小说或电影中，
but across the entire series, he follows the main elements of what we call the hero's journey. One of the things that you and others have pointed out is a hallmark of the hero's journey is not just about the plot and the events and the narrative and the things that the hero does, but an internal change that happens within the hero. Talk about this,
还是在整个系列中，他都遵循了我们所说的“英雄之旅”的主要元素。你和其他人指出的英雄之旅的一个标志，不仅仅是关于情节、事件、叙事和英雄所做的事情，而是英雄内心发生的内在变化。谈谈这个，
that the internal change that happens within the person is as much the story of the hero's journey as much as the action of the plot, if you will. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that's one of the secret powers of the hero's journey or maybe one of the reasons it's such a popular framework is this idea of it allows storywriters to make manifest an internal change
即一个人内心发生的内在变化，正如你所说，与情节的动作一样，都是英雄之旅故事的一部分。是的，绝对是。我认为这是英雄之旅的秘密力量之一，或者可能是它成为如此受欢迎的框架的原因之一，这个想法是它允许故事创作者将内在变化显现出来，
via some sort of external, obvious, sometimes fantastical version. So in the case of Harry Potter, we see this boy who does not feel like he has any powers, is not important or interesting in any way. And he comes to realize that actually there is something special about him. But that's not enough for the story. What needs to be more is he needs to learn what to do with that power, how he can make friends, how he can bring along people. And so the magic and his strength that he grows in that area ends up paralleling his internal transformation as he grows up. into a young man and figures out how to be truly a hero both in terms of how he treats other people. But the story represents that in terms of the challenges he faces and the literal transformation he has in terms of his powers.
通过某种外部的、明显的、有时是奇幻的版本。所以在哈利·波特的情况下，我们看到这个男孩觉得自己没有任何力量，在任何方面都不重要或有趣。但他开始意识到，实际上他身上确实有一些特别之处。但这对于故事来说还不够。更需要的是，他需要学习如何利用这种力量，如何结交朋友，如何带领他人。因此，他在该领域增长的魔法和力量，最终与他成长为一名年轻男子时的内在转变相平行，并弄清楚如何真正成为一名英雄，无论是在他对待他人的方式上。但故事通过他面临的挑战以及他在力量方面的字面转变来表现这一点。
You know, I'm thinking about the story now for the first time in a slightly different fashion, because I've long known that the story of Harry Potter is a story of magic. It's a story about wizards and all kinds of magical spells. But as you're talking now, I'm realizing that part of what the magic really is about, is about this internal realization, this transformation that happens within Harry, when he realizes the power that he has within himself, that's where the magic actually is. Absolutely. And you see this sort of on two tracks, but the main focus is that, you know, while it's exciting to watch someone like Harry Potter, face magical, you know, face-down dragons
你知道，我现在第一次以一种略有不同的方式思考这个故事，因为我早就知道《哈利·波特》的故事是一个关于魔法的故事。这是一个关于巫师和各种魔法咒语的故事。但正如你现在所说，我意识到魔法真正关乎的一部分，是关于这种内在的觉醒，这种发生在哈利内心的转变，当他意识到自己内在的力量时，那才是魔法真正所在的地方。绝对是。你可以在两条轨道上看到这一点，但主要的焦点是，你知道，虽然看着像哈利·波特这样的人面对魔法，你知道，面对龙，
and face-down monsters in Volda-Bort, but what really brings people back to the story time and time again, is this idea that you're watching someone transform and learn and figure out how to be an adult, how to be someone who is worth wanting to model your life after. And the hero's journey is the way to represent that psychological change on a broader, more adventurous, exciting way that people want to experience on both levels. In the 1940s band, the mythologist Joseph Campbell looked at a variety of myths across different cultures. Tell me, what he did and what he found? Yes, so Joseph Campbell was a professor of literature at Sarah Lawrence College,
面对伏地魔的怪物，但真正让人们一次又一次回到这个故事的原因，是这个想法：你正在看着一个人转变、学习并弄清楚如何成为一个成年人，如何成为一个值得你效仿生活的人。而英雄之旅是以一种更广泛、更冒险、更令人兴奋的方式来表现这种心理变化的方法，人们希望在两个层面上体验它。在20世纪40年代，本，神话学家约瑟夫·坎贝尔研究了不同文化中的各种神话。告诉我，他做了什么，发现了什么？是的，约瑟夫·坎贝尔是莎拉劳伦斯学院的文学教授，
and he worked in comparative mythology and religion. So he's looking at some of the most enduring ancient stories across the globe, so not just in terms of the West, but looking at all these stories across various areas and various cultures. And what he found was when he was looking at all of these myths and looking at these enduring stories, that there seemed to be the same basic plot line. And he ended up calling this the monomyth, but that's what we call the hero's journey.
他从事比较神话学和宗教研究。所以他研究的是全球一些最持久的古代故事，不仅仅是西方，而是观察所有这些跨越不同地区和不同文化的故事。他发现，当他观察所有这些神话和这些持久的故事时，似乎存在着相同的基本情节线。他最终称之为“单一神话”，但这就是我们所说的“英雄之旅”。
And what he attributes this to is this idea of birth and death and separating from yourself in the past. And these stories are able to represent this really profound human condition in a way that replicates and shows up. So while the individual aspects of the story might vary, Campbell was able to say, look, look at these various stories from all of these countries across the world. they actually follow the same plotline in a really interesting way, which he wrote in his book, The Hero with a Thousand Faces, which is one of the most popular narrative psychology or narrative, maybe even philosophy books that exist today. And so if you look at a story like Homer's Odyssey or the Ramayana from India or the King Arthur story or even the Bible, Joseph Campbell would argue that in some ways, you know, perhaps some of these are religious texts and some of these are just stories, but they all follow the same basic. arc, if you will. Absolutely. And if you ever read Hero with a Thousand Faces,
他将其归因于出生、死亡和与过去的自己分离的概念。这些故事能够以一种复制和显现的方式表现这种深刻的人类状况。因此，虽然故事的各个方面可能有所不同，但坎贝尔能够说，看，看看来自世界各地所有这些不同的故事，它们实际上以一种非常有趣的方式遵循着相同的情节线，他在他的书《千面英雄》中写到了这一点，这是当今最流行的叙事心理学，或者说是叙事，甚至可能是哲学书籍之一。所以如果你看看像荷马的《奥德赛》、印度的《罗摩衍那》、亚瑟王的故事，甚至是《圣经》，约瑟夫·坎贝尔会认为，在某种程度上，你知道，也许其中一些是宗教文本，而另一些只是故事，但它们都遵循相同的基本弧线，如果你愿意这样称呼的话。绝对是。如果你读过《千面英雄》，
I think what's most, what's really powerful about that book is it's told through examples from myths that you've heard of and from myths that at least I had not heard of or had not learned while I was in school. And I think that speaks to the power of this, this idea that all of these stories,
我认为那本书最强大之处在于，它是通过你听说过的神话以及至少我在学校里没有听说过或没有学过的神话中的例子来讲述的。我认为这说明了这种想法的力量，即所有这些故事，
even stories you may not have ever imagined or may not ever heard of otherwise, actually are all speaking the same language or using the same underlying plot. I understand that Joseph Campbell's work has influenced generations of Hollywood screenwriters and directors, and that includes George Lucas, who made Star Wars? Yes, absolutely.
即使是你可能从未想象过或从未听说过的故事，实际上都在说着同一种语言或使用着相同的底层情节。我了解到约瑟夫·坎贝尔的作品影响了几代好莱坞编剧和导演，其中包括制作了《星球大战》的乔治·卢卡斯？是的，绝对是。
George Lucas really attributes a lot of the success of Star Wars to Joseph Campbell, and I believe they became friends, or at least George Lucas saw Campbell as a mentor as he went along. And actually, there was a speech that I really love that George Lucas gave, I think, in 85, in which he mentioned that he had been working on many, many drafts of Star Wars. And he just couldn't quite get it to work.
乔治·卢卡斯确实将《星球大战》的巨大成功归功于约瑟夫·坎贝尔，我相信他们成为了朋友，或者至少乔治·卢卡斯在创作过程中将坎贝尔视为导师。事实上，我非常喜欢乔治·卢卡斯在85年发表的一次演讲，他在演讲中提到他一直在为《星球大战》撰写许多许多草稿。但他就是无法让它顺利进行。
There was something that wasn't clicking. And maybe in his struggles and trying to figure out how to improve the story, he actually came across the hero with a thousand faces, and suddenly it all clicked. And suddenly the story made sense. He knew how he needed to structure the plot and the overall arc of those first three films. And he even went so far as to call Joseph Campbell his Yoda, the mentor that he made. look to in terms of how to tell a good story. When we come back, we'll use the example of Star Wars to unpack the discrete elements of
有些东西没有对上号。也许在他努力想办法改进故事的过程中，他偶然发现了《千面英雄》，突然间一切都通了。突然间，故事变得有意义了。他知道如何构建情节以及前三部电影的整体弧线。他甚至称约瑟夫·坎贝尔为他的“尤达”，即他在如何讲好故事方面所仰望的导师。当我们回来时，我们将使用《星球大战》的例子来拆解英雄之旅的离散元素。
the hero's journey. We'll also look at how this framework can shape the stories we tell about our own lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. From time immemorial, people have told stories in which a brave but uncertain figure sets out on a quest, heading into the unknown in search of treasures, both external and internal.
我们还将探讨这个框架如何塑造我们讲述自己生活的故事。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。从远古时代起，人们就讲述着这样的故事：一个勇敢但又不确定的形象踏上征程，走向未知，寻找外部和内部的宝藏。
At Boston College's Carroll School of Management, Ben Rogers studies the way people make meaning from their lives. He draws some of the inspiration for this work from great books and movies that show us how characters make meaning from their journeys. Ben, according to Joseph Campbell's framework, the hero's journey has 17 elements. When you and your collaborator studied the phenomenon, you condense those elements in into seven elements. The first is what you call the emergence of a protagonist. Let's use the Star Wars movies as an example. How does Luke Skywalker emerge as a protagonist of the story? So, yes, we begin with the idea of just someone having a clear and defined character and an identity.
在波士顿学院卡罗尔管理学院，本·罗杰斯研究人们如何从生活中获取意义。他从伟大的书籍和电影中汲取了一些灵感，这些作品向我们展示了角色如何从他们的旅程中获取意义。本，根据约瑟夫·坎贝尔的框架，英雄之旅有17个元素。当你和你的合作者研究这种现象时，你们将这些元素浓缩为七个元素。第一个是你所说的“主角的出现”。让我们以《星球大战》电影为例。卢克·天行者是如何作为故事的主角出现的？是的，我们从一个拥有清晰明确的角色和身份的人的想法开始。
And specifically in a hero's journey, that often starts with the protagonist being relatively unknown, or at least not remarkable in any way that they might be aware of. And Luke Skywalker, to me, is one of the prototypical examples of the protagonist. And when we meet him in Star Wars, he's a, I believe he's a farmer on a moisture farm on Tatouine, a very set aside planet. He does not have anything that seems remarkable or magic about him. And in fact, when we first see him, he's really just dealing with the struggles and the chores that he has to face. And it does not seem like he's destined for greatness in any meaningful way. I want to play your clip from that first Star Wars film called A New Hope. In this scene, wise elder, Obi-Wan Kenobi, and the young farm boy Luke Skywalker have just viewed a holographic
具体来说，在英雄之旅中，这通常始于主角相对不为人知，或者至少在他们可能意识到的任何方面都不引人注目。对我来说，卢克·天行者是主角的原型例子之一。当我们第一次在《星球大战》中见到他时，我相信他是一个在塔图因星球（一个非常偏远的星球）上的水分农场里的农民。他身上没有任何看起来引人注目或神奇的东西。事实上，当我们第一次看到他时，他真的只是在处理他必须面对的挣扎和琐事。看起来他并没有注定要以任何有意义的方式成就伟大。我想播放一段来自第一部《星球大战》电影《新希望》的片段。在这个场景中，睿智的长者欧比旺·克诺比和年轻的农场男孩卢克·天行者刚刚观看了来自绝望的莱娅公主的全息
message from a desperate Princess Leia pleading with them for help. You must learn the ways of the force if you're to come with me to Alderan. Alderan? I'm not going to Alderan. I'm going to Alderan. I'm going to get home. It's late. I'm in for it as it is. I need your help, Luke. She needs your help. I'm getting too old for this sort of thing. I can't get involved. I've got work to do. It's not that I like the empire. I hate it, but there's nothing I can do about it right now. Talk about the idea that in many of these accounts of the hero's journey,
信息，恳求他们提供帮助。如果你要和我一起去奥德兰，你必须学习原力之道。奥德兰？我不去奥德兰。我要回家。太晚了。我本来就麻烦缠身。我需要你的帮助，卢克。她需要你的帮助。我年纪太大了，干不了这种事。我不能卷入其中。我有工作要做。并不是我不喜欢帝国。我讨厌它，但我现在无能为力。谈谈在许多这些关于英雄之旅的叙述中，
the hero is initially reluctant to get involved in. Yes. So in Joseph Campbell's version, this is called Refusal of the Call. And while it's not explicitly in our version of the condensed hero's journey, it's still a very significant part of this initial moment of shift or change that the protagonist faces. And I think it's important because people are often dealing with how do we handle huge changes in our lives? And we know from psychological research that's very difficult for people to do. And so I think that being such a key part of the hero's journey is really important because it feels authentic to the audience members.
英雄最初不愿卷入的想法。是的。在约瑟夫·坎贝尔的版本中，这被称为“拒绝召唤”。虽然它没有明确出现在我们浓缩的英雄之旅版本中，但它仍然是主角面临的最初转变或改变时刻中非常重要的一部分。我认为这很重要，因为人们经常在处理我们如何应对生活中巨大的变化。我们从心理学研究中知道，这对人们来说是非常困难的。所以我认为作为英雄之旅的关键部分，这非常重要，因为它对观众来说感觉很真实。
If they were imagining how they might experience someone going, actually, you think you're a farmer but you're destined for greatness, you might initially go, whoa, I don't know if that's quite true. And so I think that being part of the hero's journey is supposed to mimic the human experience. of how do we actually deal with these massive changes when they're thrust upon us. I'm going to play another clip from A New Hope. In this scene, Luke Skywalker returns home to his aunt and uncle's farm only to find the homestead destroyed and his relatives killed by imperial forces. Obi-Wan Kenobi consult him. There's nothing you could have done, Luke, had you been there?
如果他们想象自己可能会经历有人说，其实你以为你是农民，但你注定要成就伟大，你最初可能会想，哇，我不知道那是否完全正确。所以我认为作为英雄之旅的一部分，它是为了模仿人类的经验，即当这些巨大的变化强加给我们时，我们实际上是如何处理它们的。我要播放《新希望》中的另一个片段。在这个场景中，卢克·天行者回到他姨妈和叔叔的农场，却发现家园被摧毁，亲人被帝国军队杀害。欧比旺·克诺比安慰他。你什么也做不了，卢克，即使你在那里？
You'd have been killed, too, and the droids would now be in the hands of the empire. I want to come with you to Alderman. There's nothing for me here now. I want to learn the ways of the force and become a Jedi like my father. So this marks a moment where the reluctant hero is reluctant no longer, Ben. What's going on here in terms of the hero's journey? What's going on here is Luke, in this case, is finally being pushed beyond his refusal of the call. At a certain point, while he might be reluctant to embrace what.
你也会被杀，机器人现在就会落入帝国手中。我想和你一起去奥德兰。这里现在没有什么值得我留恋的了。我想学习原力之道，像我父亲一样成为一名绝地武士。所以这标志着一个时刻，不情愿的英雄不再不情愿了，本。在英雄之旅方面，这里发生了什么？这里发生的是，卢克在这种情况下终于被推到了拒绝召唤之外。在某种程度上，虽然他可能不愿拥抱
has been thrust upon him in terms of potentially becoming a Jedi, now that his aunt and uncle have been killed and he has to figure out what to do next, his past life is no longer tenable. There's no way he can go back to what he wanted to, so he no longer is really able to refuse that call. And in a sense, this makes his quest very simple in terms of what he should do. He wants to avenge the murder of his aunt and uncle and become powerful and be able to do that. He's using this finally kick out the door in order of, I can't go back, but now I need to really embrace and grow and learn and eventually transform.
作为绝地武士的潜力，现在他的姨妈和叔叔被杀了，他必须弄清楚下一步该做什么，他过去的生活已不再可行。他不可能回到他想要的生活，所以他真的无法再拒绝那个召唤。在某种意义上，这使得他的任务在应该做什么方面变得非常简单。他想为他姨妈和叔叔的谋杀复仇，变得强大，并能够做到这一点。他终于踢开了那扇门，因为我不能回头，但我现在需要真正拥抱、成长、学习并最终转变。
And I think you see this again and again in different versions of the hero's story. The protagonist reaches effectively a point of no return. There's no going back to the earlier life. That door has been closed. The only way to move now is forward. Yes. While all of us would like to think that when we're presented with a great opportunity, that we wouldn't sort of shirk our duties and try to live on our current lives.
我认为你在英雄故事的不同版本中一次又一次地看到这一点。主角实际上达到了一个“不归点”。没有回到以前生活的路了。那扇门已经关上了。现在唯一的前进方向就是向前。是的。虽然我们所有人都希望认为，当我们面对一个巨大的机会时，我们不会逃避责任，试图过我们目前的生活。
Often what happens in the real world and what's mirrored in our narratives is that we do need that push out the door. We need to be able to not go back and have the courage, or at least the lack of fear, to start facing the challenges. I think that's one of the things that's represented in the hero's journey that, like the refusal of the call, is really very authentic to the human experience. We talked earlier about how Star Wars was explicitly modeled on the hero's journey, as described by the mythologist Joseph Campbell. Another classic hero's journey is found in the Lord of the Rings, the series of novels by J.R.R. Tolkien.
现实世界中经常发生的事情，以及在我们的叙事中反映出来的事情是，我们确实需要那推门的一把。我们需要能够不回头，并有勇气，或者至少没有恐惧，去开始面对挑战。我认为这是英雄之旅中表现出的事情之一，就像拒绝召唤一样，对人类经验来说是非常真实的。我们之前谈到《星球大战》是如何明确地以神话学家约瑟夫·坎贝尔描述的英雄之旅为蓝本的。另一个经典的英雄之旅可以在J.R.R.托尔金的小说系列《指环王》中找到。
In this tale, the protagonist Frodo Baggins undergoes a shift and sets out on a quest, but he doesn't go alone. He finds allies. Set up the premise of the story for us, Ben, and explain why finding allies is an important part of the hero. journey. Sure. So in the telling of Lord of the Rings, and I'll make sure I try to represent it as accurately as I can, so Frodo is living at the Shire. He's living a pretty idyllic life, not really facing any monumental challenges or that many interesting stories. He is thrust upon him this challenge by Gandalf, who's a wizard. And he's told that he needs to help on this big quest to help destroy the one ring to rule them all. Evil is stirring in Mordor.
在这个故事中，主角弗罗多·巴金斯经历了一个转变并踏上了征程，但他并没有独自前行。他找到了盟友。为我们设定故事的前提，本，并解释为什么寻找盟友是英雄之旅的重要组成部分。当然。在《指环王》的讲述中，我会尽量准确地表现它，所以弗罗多住在夏尔。他过着相当田园诗般的生活，并没有真正面临任何重大的挑战或那么多有趣的故事。他被巫师甘道夫强加了这个挑战。他被告知他需要帮助完成这个摧毁至尊魔戒的大任务。邪恶正在魔多酝酿。
The ring has awoken. It's heard its master's call. But he was destroyed. Sauron was destroyed. No, Frodo. The spirit of Saron endured. And Frodo obviously doesn't want to do that. He has enjoyed his life and is continuing to enjoy it.
戒指已经觉醒。它听到了主人的召唤。但他被摧毁了。索伦被摧毁了。不，弗罗多。索伦的灵魂依然存在。弗罗多显然不想这样做。他享受着他的生活，并且正在继续享受它。
But he is pushed out by Gandalf. And along the way, he ends up making a series of other allies, Samwise Gamgee, Mary and Pip, then he meets others like Aragon, Legalis, Gimley, and lots of other people. And so this is representing this idea of allies is, while we might think of the hero as like a solitary hero on a journey, what actually is an intimate part of the hero's journey is this idea that no hero walks alone. They often only reach the distances that they're trying to reach when they're helped along by other people. And in particular, that help can sometimes be kind support, but can also be sort of being pushed out the door towards greatness.
但他被甘道夫推了出去。一路上，他最终结识了一系列其他盟友，山姆怀斯·甘姆吉、梅里和皮平，然后他遇到了像阿拉贡、莱戈拉斯、吉姆利和其他许多人。所以这代表了盟友的想法，虽然我们可能认为英雄是旅途中的孤独英雄，但英雄之旅中一个亲密的部分实际上是这个想法：没有英雄是独自前行的。他们往往只有在其他人的帮助下才能达到他们试图达到的距离。特别是，这种帮助有时可以是友善的支持，但也可以是那种被推向伟大的门外。
Now, along the way, Frodo encounters innumerable challenges, and of course, this is an essential component of the hero's journey. Absolutely. Facing challenges is both representative of the human life, but it's also what makes a really interesting story. I have a young four-year-old daughter, and we read lots of stories at night. And while the stories are fun and clever, they often don't have a lot of challenges or stakes about them. And so they're not stories that I'm always jumping to repeat. But Heroes Journeys, on the other hands, are these stories filled with monsters and nemeses and all of these different things that people are trying to overcome.
现在，一路上，弗罗多遇到了无数的挑战，当然，这是英雄之旅的重要组成部分。绝对是。面对挑战既是人类生活的代表，也是让故事变得非常有趣的原因。我有一个四岁的女儿，我们晚上读很多故事。虽然这些故事很有趣且聪明，但它们往往没有太多的挑战或利害关系。所以它们不是我总是急于重复的故事。但英雄之旅则不同，这些故事充满了怪物、宿敌以及人们试图克服的所有这些不同的东西。
And it gives it a sense of excitement, but also a sense of things could go wrong. We're riding a knife's edge here. And I think that's what makes a really powerful story. Talk about the idea that as the protagonist faces these, challenges, the protagonist undergoes personal transformations. And in some ways, that is key to the hero's journey. So it'd be one thing to face challenges and just immediately win them. And that might be a satisfying story on some level, but that wouldn't be a story that people might come back to. What we really like to see in our protagonists is this idea that we face challenges, we face
它给人一种兴奋感，但也给人一种事情可能会出错的感觉。我们正走在刀刃上。我认为这就是让故事变得如此强大的原因。谈谈这个想法，即当主角面对这些挑战时，主角经历了个人转变。在某种程度上，这是英雄之旅的关键。所以面对挑战并立即赢得胜利是一回事，这在某种程度上可能是一个令人满意的故事，但这不会是一个人们可能会回过头来重温的故事。我们真正喜欢在主角身上看到的是这个想法：我们面对挑战，我们面对
things that we don't know if we can overcome. And we realize that as a result of facing those challenges, we become transformed. Now, in a lot of stories, that's a literal transformation. So you might gain magical powers, gain superpowers in various superhero films, but that often parallels or goes along with a personal transformation of realizing maybe you're stronger than you thought you were, or realizing some sort of depth of character that might not have ever been apparent had you not had to face these challenges and figure out, can you face them down on your own.
我们不知道是否能克服的事情。我们意识到，作为面对这些挑战的结果，我们发生了转变。现在，在许多故事中，这是一种字面的转变。所以你可能会获得魔法力量，在各种超级英雄电影中获得超能力，但这通常与意识到你可能比你想象的更强大，或者意识到某种可能从未显现出来的性格深度相平行或伴随，如果你不必面对这些挑战并弄清楚，你能否独自面对它们。
And this is true for Frodo in The Lord of the Rings. He starts out being, you know, small and inexperienced and sheltered, and he eventually discovers in some ways the hero within. It's one of the things I love most about Lord of the Rings is the idea that Frodo as a Hobbit, you know, is both sort of unknown and unremarkable in terms of his character at the start, but he's also pretty unremarkable in terms of his stature. The hobbits are literally small. And what's great about the Lord of the Rings and the journey that he goes on
这对《指环王》中的弗罗多来说也是如此。他开始时，你知道，渺小、缺乏经验且受到庇护，他最终在某种程度上发现了内在的英雄。这是我最喜欢《指环王》的一点，即弗罗多作为一个霍比特人，你知道，在开始时，他的性格既不为人知也不引人注目，但他在身材方面也相当平庸。霍比特人字面上很小。而《指环王》以及他所经历的旅程的伟大之处在于
is Frodo and some of the other hobbits as well end up being some of the most heroic characters. They're the ones who stand up to take the ring to try to destroy it at the end when other people are too nervous. So both in terms of their stature, but also in terms of their character, more importantly, they go through this transformation and end up being the ones that people really remember and identify with. So in the stories that we've talked about so far, you can see the similarities. You know, Harry Potter starts out as this orphan kid who basically has been ignored and discarded by society. Luke Skywalker starts off as this farm boy. Frodo Baggins is this unremarkable hobbit.
弗罗多和其他一些霍比特人最终成为了最英勇的角色。当其他人太紧张时，他们是挺身而出带走戒指试图摧毁它的人。所以无论是在身材方面，还是更重要的性格方面，他们都经历了这种转变，并最终成为了人们真正记住并认同的人。所以到目前为止我们谈论的故事中，你可以看到相似之处。你知道，哈利·波特开始时是一个基本上被社会忽视和抛弃的孤儿。卢克·天行者开始时是一个农场男孩。弗罗多·巴金斯是一个平庸的霍比特人。
And you can start to see now why these stories appeal to so many people, because people feel, you know, I am unremarkable, I am ordinary. And what these stories are telling you is, you are not. Absolutely. I think there is a strong degree of identification. and the most powerful stories are the ones that, while it might be circumstances that we never actually find ourselves in, it's really enjoyable to imagine what would I do in that case. And the hero's journey kind of takes you from this unremarkable baseline protagonist, farmer, orphan, etc., to something more powerful. And if you follow along in that journey as the reader, you're also going on that journey yourself where, while you might not be the one,
你现在可以开始明白为什么这些故事吸引了这么多人，因为人们觉得，你知道，我是平庸的，我是普通的。而这些故事告诉你的是，你不是。绝对是。我认为有一种强烈的认同感，而最强大的故事是那些，虽然这可能是我们从未真正发现自己所处的环境，但想象一下在这种情况下我会做什么是非常有趣的。英雄之旅把你从这个平庸的基准主角（农民、孤儿等）带向更强大的东西。如果你作为读者跟随那个旅程，你也在经历那个旅程，虽然你可能不是那个
who's literally gaining magical powers or superpowers, but you're in the perspective of the reader, and it feels like you're developing some deep personal insight by following the steps of this journey. The seventh and final element of a hero's journey that you've identified involves leaving a legacy. What is this idea, Ben? Yes, the legacy is this idea of making some sort of positive impact.
字面上获得魔法力量或超能力的人，但你处于读者的视角，感觉你通过遵循这个旅程的步骤正在发展一些深刻的个人洞察力。你确定的英雄之旅的第七个也是最后一个元素涉及留下遗产。这个想法是什么，本？是的，遗产是产生某种积极影响的想法。
And in a lot of heroes journeys, people might think that it ends where they become transformed, They gain some magical superpowers and they defeat their enemy, but most of those stories don't end right there. They actually go on a little bit longer to show how the hero goes back to their home community to share either literal or metaphorical treasures with those around them. They often repair relationships that they had. They help people with whether that's the new depth of character or their new powers. They're able to give back in a really profound way to show that, yes, you've transformed personally, but that also can transform the communities around us.
在许多英雄之旅中，人们可能认为它在他们转变时就结束了，他们获得了某种魔法超能力并击败了敌人，但大多数故事并没有在那里结束。它们实际上继续了一点点，以展示英雄如何回到他们的家乡社区，与周围的人分享字面或隐喻的宝藏。他们经常修复他们拥有的关系。他们帮助人们，无论是通过新的性格深度还是他们的新力量。他们能够以一种非常深刻的方式回馈，以表明，是的，你个人已经转变了，但这也可以改变我们周围的社区。
Does that happen with Frodo and the Lord of the Rings? Yes, so in the books, Frodo ends up going back and helping to restore the Shire. So as a result of the events that transpire in the story, the Shire is destroyed or at least put in terms of really bad circumstances. And so Frodo actually returns back to his homeland at the end to help restore his homeland and sort of rescue his fellow hobbits. Just as screenwriters and directors make choices about how to tell a fictional story, all of us make choices about how we tell the stories of our lives.
弗罗多在《指环王》中是这样吗？是的，在书中，弗罗多最终回去帮助恢复夏尔。因此，作为故事中发生的事件的结果，夏尔被摧毁了，或者至少处于非常糟糕的环境中。所以弗罗多最终在最后回到了他的家乡，帮助恢复他的家乡并拯救了他的霍比特同胞。正如编剧和导演在如何讲述虚构故事时做出选择一样，我们所有人在讲述我们生活的故事时也做出选择。
When we come back, applying the framework of the hero's journey to our own stories. In our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at several practical techniques to help you discover the hero's journey in your own life story. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled Discovering Your Inner Hero. If you're not yet a subscriber, please give it a try. You can get a free seven-day trial at support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain.
当我们回来时，将英雄之旅的框架应用于我们自己的故事。在我们《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套剧集中，我们研究了几种实用的技巧，帮助你发现自己人生故事中的英雄之旅。如果你是订阅者，该剧集现在就可以收听。标题是《发现你内在的英雄》。如果你还不是订阅者，请尝试一下。你可以在 support.hiddenbrain.org 获得七天的免费试用。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。
Your support does more than give you access to all our subscriber-only content. You're also helping to support the careful research, writing, fact-checking, and sound design that go into every episode of the show. Again, those sites are support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When you think about your own life, what is the narrative that comes most easily to mind? How would you say this narrative affects the way you think about your own life?
你的支持不仅仅让你能够访问我们所有的订阅者专属内容。你还在帮助支持每一集节目背后的严谨研究、写作、事实核查和声音设计。再次重申，这些网站是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com/hiddenbrain。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当你想到自己的生活时，最容易浮现在脑海中的叙事是什么？你会说这种叙事如何影响你思考自己生活的方式？
If you would be willing to share your story with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, Heroes Journey. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Social scientist Ben Rogers explores how people make meaning from their lives. He has studied how retelling the story of our lives,
如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享你的故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org，主题行使用“Heroes Journey”。再次重申，那是 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。社会科学家本·罗杰斯探索人们如何从生活中获取意义。他研究了如何重述我们生活的故事，
using the framework of a hero's journey, can change our psychological well-being. Ben, you and your collaborators have developed a scale that measures how much an individual's life story resembles the framework of a hero's journey. You've evaluated the life stories of a large group of people using this instrument. Do some people report having a hero's journey that runs through their lives? We surveyed a number of people and we collected a lot of life stories. And like all psychological constructs, there's a heavy degree of variability where some people are very high on the hero's journey. They see the elements of the hero's journey in their own lives,
使用英雄之旅的框架，可以改变我们的心理健康。本，你和你的合作者开发了一个量表，衡量一个人的生活故事在多大程度上类似于英雄之旅的框架。你们使用这个工具评估了一大群人的生活故事。有些人报告说他们的生活中贯穿着英雄之旅吗？我们调查了许多人，并收集了许多生活故事。像所有的心理学结构一样，存在着很大程度的变异性，有些人非常符合英雄之旅。他们看到了自己生活中英雄之旅的元素，
or they tell their story often featuring a lot of these elements. But also some people don't. Some people say in our stories, I don't see my story in that way. I have lived an unremarkable life. Or they write on a questionnaire that we have that they don't feel like those elements of the hero's journey are heavily present in their lives. I'm wondering the people who report their lives as a hero's journey,
或者他们讲述的故事经常包含许多这些元素。但也有一些人没有。有些人说在我们的故事中，我没有以那种方式看待我的故事。我过着平庸的生活。或者他们在我们拥有的问卷上写道，他们不觉得英雄之旅的那些元素在他们的生活中非常明显。我想知道那些报告他们的生活是英雄之旅的人，
did you notice anything about their mental well-being? their satisfaction about their lives? Yes, we asked a series of different questions, but the main one that we were focused on and what we saw repeated time and time again in our studies was that the people who either saw their life as a hero's journey or told their story naturally as a hero's journey, those were the people who also reported feeling like their lives were highly meaningful, that they had a lot of meaning in their life in terms of their life felt significant, it felt purposeful, felt very coherent.
你注意到他们心理健康方面的任何事情了吗？他们对生活的满意度？是的，我们问了一系列不同的问题，但我们关注的主要问题以及我们在研究中一次又一次看到重复出现的是，那些要么将自己的生活视为英雄之旅，要么自然地将自己的故事讲述为英雄之旅的人，这些人也报告说感觉他们的生活非常有意义，他们在生活中有很多意义，就他们的生活感觉很重要、感觉有目的、感觉非常连贯而言。
And this was exciting to us to find that the way that you see your life story or the way that you might naturally tell it seem to have this profound impact on the types of attitudes that people carry around with them in terms of their mental well-being. And what about the people who did not tell their life stories in the form of a hero's journey? What did their personal narratives look like, Ben? Yes, their life stories took a number of different forms. So I'd say one of the most common versions in terms of the studies that we collected is people would just write stories of this happened to me and then this happened to me, sort of like a series of biographical steps of I grew up here, I went to college here, or I didn't go to college, and this is what happened.
我们很高兴发现，你看待自己生活故事的方式，或者你自然讲述它的方式，似乎对人们随身携带的心理健康态度产生了这种深远的影响。那么那些没有以英雄之旅形式讲述自己生活故事的人呢？他们的个人叙事是什么样的，本？是的，他们的生活故事采取了许多不同的形式。所以我说，就我们收集的研究而言，最常见的版本之一是人们只是写下“这发生在我身上，然后那发生在我身上”的故事，有点像一系列传记步骤，比如“我在这里长大，我在这里上大学，或者我没上大学，这就是发生的事情”。
So sort of just a checking the mark on literally the events that had happened without any connective tissues. Now, the other examples that we would see is sometimes people would tell these stories of what some psychological researchers called contamination narratives, but we also saw versions where people were saying, I had all this promise in my early days, and I either didn't fulfill it or situations outside of my own control happened, and I ended up either plateauing or ended up in a state that I'm not particularly proud of right now. And so instead of being able to face challenges and transform, people might have faced those same challenges and felt like they were not able to succeed in the way that they wanted. What were the psychological effects of constructing these narratives that featured, you know,
所以有点像是在字面上勾选已经发生的事件，没有任何连接组织。现在，我们看到的其他例子是，有时人们会讲述一些心理学研究人员所说的“污染叙事”，但我们也看到了人们说“我在早期有很多希望，但我要么没有实现它，要么发生了我无法控制的情况，我最终要么停滞不前，要么陷入了一种我现在并不特别引以为豪的状态”的版本。所以，人们没有能够面对挑战并转变，而是可能面对了同样的挑战，并觉得他们没能以他们想要的方式成功。构建这些以……为特征的叙事有什么心理影响？
stagnant or downward trajectories? Yes, we looked at a number of different outcomes. I think the ones that are most useful to call out was we looked at how resilient people felt that their lives were. So if they were facing personal problems, people who often told these contamination narratives or these narratives where they felt stuck did not feel well equipped in order to face down those challenges. So they would report that they either tried to ignore personal problems or that they didn't
停滞或向下轨迹？是的，我们研究了许多不同的结果。我认为最值得一提的是，我们研究了人们觉得他们的生活有多大的韧性。所以如果他们面临个人问题，那些经常讲述这些污染叙事或他们感到被困住的叙事的人，并没有觉得他们有能力面对这些挑战。所以他们会报告说，他们要么试图忽视个人问题，要么他们不
know how to face them. They felt really powerless. And we also looked at depressive symptoms, so not a clinical diagnosis, but the idea that people are saying, my mood right now, I feel very downtrodden. I feel like I don't have a lot going for me. And the people who told those life stories in that way often reported feeling more in terms of that negative well-being. Now, of course, it could be that the stories that people are telling about their lives are simply accurately reflecting their lives. And so if one person, you know, has a series of successes and has a lot of breaks and, you know, starts out, you know, not in great shape, but ends up
知道如何面对它们。他们感到非常无力。我们还研究了抑郁症状，所以不是临床诊断，而是人们说“我此刻的心情，我感到非常沮丧。我觉得我没有什么好运”的想法。而以这种方式讲述生活故事的人，往往报告说在负面心理健康方面感觉更多。当然，人们讲述关于自己生活的故事可能只是准确地反映了他们的生活。所以如果一个人，你知道，有一系列的成功，有很多机会，并且，你知道，开始时，你知道，状态不太好，但最终
in great shape, you know, it's easy for them to tell it. triumphant story, a hero's journey type of story. If somebody's life has taken a different turn, if they've experienced illness and setbacks and divorce and separations and tragedy, you know, you could say that their lives, in fact, reflect a downward trajectory. So I think a reasonable question to ask Ben is, as you hear these stories from people, do you think that people's lives are predicting their psychological well-being or the stories that people are telling about their lives are predicting their psychological well-being? That's such an interesting question, and I think it's one we grappled with a lot as we were doing this work of,
状态很好，你知道，他们很容易讲述这个故事。一个胜利的故事，一种英雄之旅类型的故事。如果某人的生活发生了不同的转折，如果他们经历了疾病、挫折、离婚、分离和悲剧，你知道，你可以说他们的生活实际上反映了一条向下的轨迹。所以我认为问本一个合理的问题是，当你听到人们讲述这些故事时，你认为人们的生活是在预测他们的心理健康，还是人们讲述的关于他们生活的故事在预测他们的心理健康？这是一个非常有趣的问题，我认为这也是我们在做这项工作时经常纠结的问题，
are we just showing that people who live really heroic or really positive lives feel very positive about their life? That would be interesting on some level, but would not be speaking to sort of the powerful versions of the life story in and of itself. And so what we would say is based on the stories that we collected is often people who rated their lives as high on a hero's journey. they were living lives that might not be on from the outside a story that you might go they're obviously going to feel like they have a highly meaningful life some of the stories that people would report to me were facing some extremely difficult circumstances people who had been in and out of prison who had dealt with substance abuse who had dealt with relationship issues things where people would say i've had this i've had a really tough life and maybe i'm not rich and famous or a huge
我们是否只是在证明那些过着真正英雄般或非常积极生活的人对他们的生活感觉非常积极？这在某种程度上会很有趣，但并不能说明生活故事本身那种强大的版本。所以我们要说的是，根据我们收集的故事，那些将自己的生活评价为高度符合英雄之旅的人，往往过着从外部看可能不会被认为是一个你会觉得他们显然会觉得生活非常有意义的故事的生活。有些人向我报告的故事是面临一些极其困难的情况，那些曾经进出监狱、处理过药物滥用、处理过关系问题的人，人们会说我经历过这些，我过着非常艰难的生活，也许我不富有、不出名，也不是一个巨大的
hero, but I've been a hero within the context of my life. Maybe I've shown a lot of resilience. Maybe I've helped people who have faced similar circumstances. And so that to me speaks to some of this of the stories that were really high in terms of hero's journeys were not always stories that were just massively amazing from the outside. Sometimes they were really heartbreaking, but in a way that people seem to find deeper meaning out of them. So you and your colleagues have given a lot of thought to why the hero's journey might be such a powerful formula, both on the screen as well as in real life. One idea is that the brain simply is hardwired for story and the hero's journey makes for a better story. Yes, so there's
英雄，但我是在我生活的背景下成为了英雄。也许我表现出了很大的韧性。也许我帮助过面临类似情况的人。所以对我来说，这说明了一些故事，那些在英雄之旅方面得分非常高的故事并不总是从外部看就非常了不起的故事。有时它们真的很令人心碎，但以一种人们似乎能从中找到更深层意义的方式。所以你和你的同事们对为什么英雄之旅可能是一个如此强大的公式思考了很多，无论是在银幕上还是在现实生活中。一个想法是，大脑天生就是为故事而生的，而英雄之旅造就了更好的故事。是的，所以有
work out of evolutionary psychology that speaks to this idea that, as you said, our brains are just wired for stories. And the idea being that when, you know, back in cave person days, there's a lot of uncertainty about the world. You might eat something and fall ill. You might face some sort of animal and not know what to do. And so the idea being that humans learned how to tell these succinct, meaningful stories or packages of information in a way that people would be able to remember that and multiply that over thousands and millions of experiences and across thousands of years is our brains still seem pretty oriented to respond to stories in a powerful way. And you see this across a lot of different research. We see that, you know, in the courtroom,
进化心理学的工作谈到了这个观点，正如你所说，我们的大脑天生就是为故事而生的。这个想法是，你知道，在穴居人时代，对世界有很多不确定性。你可能会吃某种东西而生病。你可能会面对某种动物而不知道该怎么办。所以这个想法是，人类学会了如何讲述这些简洁、有意义的故事或信息包，以便人们能够记住它，并将其在成千上万和数百万次的经验中以及数千年的时间里成倍增加，我们的大脑似乎仍然非常倾向于以强大的方式对故事做出反应。你在许多不同的研究中都能看到这一点。我们看到，你知道，在法庭上，
if lawyers tell their, you know, closing arguments in terms of a narrative versus just facts, that that's way more successful. You can look at the marketing world. Any commercial that you might see is often a miniature version of a story versus them just highlighting the pros and cons of their product. We just are really oriented towards stories, and both marketers and anyone who's trying to communicate information will often lean on stories because it helps people remember it, and it helps us know what framework and how do we take that information and act upon it. We've talked about the idea of contamination stories in our conversation. Researchers have also looked at what's called a redemptive arc.
如果律师用叙事而不是仅仅用事实来陈述他们的结案陈词，那会成功得多。你可以看看营销世界。你看到的任何商业广告通常都是故事的微缩版本，而不是仅仅强调他们产品的优缺点。我们确实非常倾向于故事，营销人员和任何试图传达信息的人通常都会依赖故事，因为它有助于人们记住它，并帮助我们知道框架是什么，以及我们如何利用这些信息并据此采取行动。我们在谈话中讨论了污染故事的概念。研究人员还研究了所谓的救赎弧线。
Now, we've talked about the idea of redemptive stories on the show previously as well, Ben. But what is a redemptive arc, and how is it different from a contamination story? Yes, so a redemptive arc or redemptive narrative. A lot of this work is done by Dan McAdams, who is actually as part of the Heroes' paper along with my fellow collaborators, a redemptive arc is quite simply a story that starts negative or starts maybe neutral and ends up positive in some way. It has a positive arc in terms of the end of the story. A contamination narrative in contrast is one that might start positive and end up negative in some profound way. And research has looked at people who tell their stories
现在，我们在节目中之前也讨论过救赎故事的概念，本。但是什么是救赎弧线，它与污染故事有什么不同？是的，所以救赎弧线或救赎叙事。这项工作大部分是由丹·麦克亚当斯完成的，他实际上是英雄论文的一部分，连同我的合作者，救赎弧线很简单，就是一个以负面开始或可能以中性开始，并以某种方式以正面结束的故事。就故事的结尾而言，它有一个积极的弧线。相比之下，污染叙事是一个可能以正面开始，并以某种深刻的方式以负面结束的故事。研究人员观察了那些讲述自己故事的人
as either a redemptive arc or a contamination art will feel profound results in terms of their well-being, the extent that they want to help others in their lives. So the way that we tell these stories is really important. And the hero's journey is an example of a redemptive arc, though it contains with it some additional elements. Now, the hero's journey also pulls together different elements that increase people's sense of meaning. You know, as we discussed, the hero's journey features a protagonist who has agency, a protagonist who experiences psychological growth, a protagonist who seeks out friendship with allies, each of these things has been shown to have psychological benefits on its own.
无论是作为救赎弧线还是污染弧线，在他们的幸福感、他们想要帮助生活中他人的程度方面都会感受到深远的结果。所以我们讲述这些故事的方式非常重要。英雄之旅是救赎弧线的一个例子，尽管它包含了一些额外的元素。现在，英雄之旅还汇集了不同的元素，增加了人们的意义感。你知道，正如我们所讨论的，英雄之旅的特点是一个有能动性的主角，一个经历心理成长的主角，一个寻求与盟友建立友谊的主角，这些事情中的每一件都被证明本身就具有心理益处。
Yes, we see the hero's journey as this really succinct, compelling package of a lot of work that has been done in psychology and social psychology and even organizational behavior over the years. So running through the elements relatively briefly with protagonists, we know that, you know, feeling in charge of your own destiny, feeling like you have a clear sense of yourself, there's a lot of work that shows that that relates to meaning in life. We know in terms of shifts of experiences that people who are high on the personality trait of openness to experience, they often rate their lives as more meaningful. In terms of quests, having a sense of purpose or goals is strongly linked to meaning in life. Having allies, so social support is probably the most robust predictor of meaning in life amongst all of the other things.
是的，我们将英雄之旅视为多年来在心理学、社会心理学甚至组织行为学领域所做的大量工作的简洁、引人注目的包。所以简要地回顾一下这些元素，对于主角，我们知道，你知道，感觉掌控自己的命运，感觉对自己有清晰的认识，有很多研究表明这与生活意义有关。我们知道，就经验的转变而言，那些在开放性人格特质上得分较高的人，他们往往认为自己的生活更有意义。就追求而言，有目标感或目标与生活意义密切相关。拥有盟友，所以社会支持可能是所有其他因素中生活意义最稳健的预测指标。
And then in terms of facing challenges and transformation, there's a lot of work that shows that people really do find profound meaning out of facing, growth. and dealing with challenges in their lives. And then in terms of legacy, there's a lot of work that shows that being pro-social, helping, donating to others, is strongly related to a sense of meaning in life. So what the hero's journey narrative does, maybe consciously, maybe just by coincidence, who knows,
然后就面对挑战和转变而言，有很多研究表明，人们确实从面对、成长和处理生活中的挑战中找到了深刻的意义。然后就遗产而言，有很多研究表明，亲社会、帮助、捐赠给他人与生活意义感密切相关。所以英雄之旅叙事所做的，也许是有意识的，也许只是巧合，谁知道呢，
is this idea that we have all of this like menu items of things that can make life feel more meaningful, and how do we put this into a succinct narrative that people want to listen to? I understand that you and your colleagues have wondered, if it's possible to help people shape their life stories into a form that resembles a hero's journey. You've administered this restorifying intervention to a group of some 1,700 volunteers. Have you found the intervention works?
就是这个想法，我们有所有这些像菜单项一样的东西，可以让生活感觉更有意义，我们如何把这些放入一个人们愿意听的简洁叙事中？我知道你和你的同事们一直在想，是否有可能帮助人们将他们的生活故事塑造成类似于英雄之旅的形式。你们已经对大约1700名志愿者进行了这种重构叙事的干预。你们发现这种干预有效吗？
Can you increase the meaning that people are perceiving in their lives? This was one of the things that we were sort of worried about in terms of this work, is this idea that we're showing that this narrative matters, and we had looked at it a number of different ways from looking at how people see their life, tell their life, controlling for various psychological factors, but there is still something about we want this to be useful for people. We don't want just the people who naturally tell their stories life as a hero's journey to be the only ones to experience these meaning benefits.
你能增加人们在生活中感知到的意义吗？这是我们在做这项工作时有点担心的事情之一，这个想法是我们正在证明这种叙事很重要，我们已经从人们如何看待生活、讲述生活、控制各种心理因素等多个方面进行了研究，但仍然有一些东西是我们希望它对人们有用。我们不希望只有那些自然地将生活故事讲述为英雄之旅的人才能体验到这些意义上的好处。
And so we sought to develop an intervention to see, can we help people guide them in terms of retelling their story as a hero's journey? And as a result of doing this intervention, what we found were many of the same benefits that we had seen just out of people who naturally told their story that way. As a result of taking our intervention, people reported their life meaning to be higher. They reported that they felt like they were flourishing in their life. They reported fewer depressive symptoms.
因此，我们试图开发一种干预措施，看看我们能否帮助人们引导他们将自己的故事重述为英雄之旅？作为进行这种干预的结果，我们发现了很多与那些自然地以这种方式讲述故事的人所看到的相同的益处。作为接受我们干预的结果，人们报告他们的生活意义更高。他们报告说他们觉得自己在生活中蓬勃发展。他们报告的抑郁症状更少。
And importantly, they also felt more resilient. They felt more ready to face down life's challenges that might continue to face them in the future. You also discovered something very interesting and surprising. which is this restorifying intervention increased the tendency among volunteers to perceive more meaning, even in something as a random string of letters on a computer screen. Talk about this finding and what it means. This was a study that we had the idea about and we wanted to see if what we were talking about in terms of seeing your life as a hero's journey helps kind of raise your expectations
重要的是，他们也感到更有韧性。他们觉得更准备好面对未来可能继续面临的生活挑战。你们还发现了一些非常有趣和令人惊讶的事情。那就是这种重构叙事的干预增加了志愿者感知更多意义的倾向，即使是在电脑屏幕上的一串随机字母中。谈谈这个发现及其意义。这是一个我们有想法的研究，我们想看看我们所谈论的将生活视为英雄之旅是否有助于提高你的期望
and raise your connection in terms of making meaning, then that might have other behavioral benefits that are not just related to, yes, my life feels more meaningful. And so we ran a study in which we had participants, look at these random strings of letters. And the task was, to what extent do you find patterns in these strings of letters?
并提高你在创造意义方面的联系，那么这可能会有其他行为上的好处，而不仅仅是与“是的，我的生活感觉更有意义”相关。所以我们进行了一项研究，让参与者观察这些随机的字母串。任务是，你在多大程度上在这些字母串中发现了模式？
And so we had one group of participants, take the heroes journey intervention, and we had one group, just do a random reflection on basic aspects of their lives. And what we found was for the participants who had done the restoring intervention, they seemed more primed to just see more meaning overall. And so while these just looked like strange strings of letters, they actually reported that they felt like there was higher amount of patterns, that there were some underlying aspect to these strings of letters beyond just complete randomness. And this sort of pointed us to this fact of being in this mindset of, yes, my life is more meaningful. So there must just be more meaning around me.
所以我们让一组参与者接受了英雄之旅的干预，我们让一组参与者只是对他们生活的基本方面进行随机反思。我们发现，对于那些进行了重构干预的参与者，他们似乎更倾向于看到更多的整体意义。因此，虽然这些看起来只是奇怪的字母串，但他们实际上报告说，他们觉得模式的数量更多，在这些字母串中存在一些超越完全随机性的潜在方面。这指向了我们处于“是的，我的生活更有意义”这种心态的事实。所以我的周围一定有更多的意义。
it's actually putting us into a mindset to find more meaning everywhere that we can find it. So this tendency to find more meaning in random stimuli is related to our ability to see more positive meaning in our personal problems, Ben? I think it really goes back to this idea of connection. And to what extent are we making connections between aspects of our lives? So just as the participants in that study seem to find these hidden connections within these strings of letters, when we ask people, are you able to solve? personal problems. The idea of can I make connections between the resources that I have, the allies that I have, past experiences that I had, if you're able to make those connections in a more easily accessible way, you're going to feel more equipped to face down difficult personal problems. And that was a study that we ran where we had people do the hero's journey
它实际上让我们进入了一种在任何地方都能找到更多意义的心态。那么这种在随机刺激中找到更多意义的倾向与我们看到个人问题中更多积极意义的能力有关吗，本？我认为这真的回到了这个联系的概念。我们在多大程度上在生活的各个方面之间建立联系？所以就像那项研究中的参与者似乎在这些字母串中找到了隐藏的联系一样，当我们问人们，你能够解决个人问题吗？关于我是否能在拥有的资源、拥有的盟友、过去的经历之间建立联系的想法，如果你能以一种更容易获得的方式建立这些联系，你就会觉得更有能力面对困难的个人问题。这就是我们进行的一项研究，我们让人们进行英雄之旅
intervention and ask them, how might you actually solve this problem in the course of the next month. And then we rated it in terms of how adaptive were the solutions that were coming up with. So people who may not have taken the hero's journey intervention, they were sometimes more likely to say, you know, this is a difficult problem. I just don't think I know how to solve it. But the people who had done the hero's journey intervention who are sort of primed to find more meaning, find more purpose, they were more likely to try to make those connections, solve their problems, and figure out, you know, how do I actually tackle this in a meaningful way? A reminder that if you have a question or comment about this episode or a story that reveals
干预并问他们，在接下来的一个月里，你实际上可能如何解决这个问题。然后我们根据他们提出的解决方案的适应性进行了评分。所以那些可能没有接受英雄之旅干预的人，他们有时更有可能说，你知道，这是一个困难的问题。我只是不认为我知道如何解决它。但是那些进行了英雄之旅干预的人，他们被引导去寻找更多的意义，寻找更多的目标，他们更有可能尝试建立这些联系，解决他们的问题，并弄清楚，你知道，我如何真正以一种有意义的方式解决这个问题？提醒一下，如果你对这一集有疑问或评论，或者有一个揭示
the hero's journey in your own life that you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at HiddenBrain.org. Use the subject line, Heroes Journey. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Ben, I'm wondering whether you've tried to discover the hero's journey in your own life? I have, yes.
你自己生活中英雄之旅的故事，并且愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们：Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。使用主题行：Heroes Journey。再说一遍，那是Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。本，我想知道你是否尝试过在自己的生活中发现英雄之旅？是的，我有。
It's one of those things that researchers often call what we do me search, where you realize that what you're studying actually relates to some profound experience that you've had in your life. And so, yes, I have absolutely applied this framework to my own life in a way that's really had profound benefits for me. Tell me a little bit about that. I understand that as a young person, You were a happy-go-lucky child and a teenager who hadn't really experienced much adversity. If you want to tell your own life story as a hero's journey, how would you tell it?
这是研究人员经常称之为“我搜索”的事情之一，当你意识到你正在研究的东西实际上与你生活中经历过的某种深刻的经历有关时。所以，是的，我绝对将这个框架应用到了我自己的生活中，这对我产生了非常深远的好处。跟我谈谈那个。我知道作为一个年轻人，你是一个无忧无虑的孩子和青少年，并没有真正经历过太多的逆境。如果你想把自己的生活故事讲述为英雄之旅，你会怎么讲？
So, as you mentioned, I had had a really great childhood. I was headed off as an 18-year-old to the University of Texas at Austin. I was going to study finance and liberal arts. And I had a great group of friends. Everything seemed great, although unremarkable. I did not feel like I was destined for any broader sense of meaning. In fact, I figured I'd join the corporate world and maybe become a consultant or do other types of things. But shortly before I headed off to college, I had what I look at now is a really profound moment of shift.
所以，正如你提到的，我有一个非常棒的童年。我18岁时前往德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校。我打算学习金融和文科。我有一群很棒的朋友。一切看起来都很棒，尽管并不引人注目。我不觉得我注定会有任何更广泛的意义感。事实上，我想我会加入企业界，也许成为一名顾问或做其他类型的事情。但在我上大学前不久，我经历了我现在看来是一个非常深刻的转变时刻。
Right before I headed off to orientation, my mom got really sick and had what we thought was appendicitis. Over time, over the next month or two, we quickly realized that she had stage four pancreatic cancer. And within just my first freshman year at college, she passed away from the disease. And as someone who had never really experienced death before and had by all other measures of pretty fortunate life, this was obviously something I was ill-equipped to deal with and was something that I needed to figure out. And that, while I didn't know it at the time, was really my quest in college. My studies were going fine and I was making friends. But looking back on it, I was really lost.
就在我前往迎新会之前，我妈妈病得很重，得了我们认为是阑尾炎的病。随着时间的推移，在接下来的一个月或两个月里，我们很快意识到她患了第四期胰腺癌。就在我大学一年级的时候，她就因病去世了。作为一个以前从未真正经历过死亡，并且在所有其他衡量标准下都过着相当幸运生活的人，这显然是我无法应对的事情，也是我需要弄清楚的事情。虽然我当时不知道，但这确实是我大学时代的追求。我的学业进展顺利，我也结交了朋友。但回想起来，我真的很迷茫。
I really needed to figure out how to deal with this profound change in my life. And like many of the hero's journeys that we had talked about, I wanted to refuse the call. I didn't want to change as a result of this experience because I really didn't want this experience to have happened. And so I wanted to put it away into a box and not have to return to it. But what I realized over time was I needed to deal with it. I needed to find some sort of broader sense of meaning. And that really became something that I came back to time and time. again in college. And with the friends that I made in college and I actually met my wife while I was
我真的需要弄清楚如何处理我生活中这种深刻的变化。就像我们谈论过的许多英雄之旅一样，我想拒绝这个召唤。我不想因为这次经历而改变，因为我真的不希望这次经历发生。所以我想把它放进盒子里，不必再回到它。但我随着时间的推移意识到我需要处理它。我需要找到某种更广泛的意义感。这确实成为了我在大学里一次又一次回到的事情。和我大学里结交的朋友，我实际上是在我
an undergrad at UT Austin, they helped me sort of realize that this was a very important thing in my life. And this was a challenge that I really needed to face. And the way I ended up transforming as a result of it is I ended up, you know, after a short career in terms of consulting, realized that I actually felt a grander calling. I wanted to go back and do academic research to understand a little bit more about how people deal with things such as this. And I very quickly gravitated towards meaning research and narrative research as a way to find meaning. And that brought me to work on the hero's journey very profoundly. I felt like I was called to study it. And specifically with the intervention piece is not just saying, you know, it's nice to have meaning and some people
在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校读本科时遇到了我的妻子，他们帮助我意识到这是我生活中非常重要的事情。这是一个我真正需要面对的挑战。我最终因此而转变的方式是，我在短暂的咨询职业生涯后，意识到我实际上感受到了一个更宏大的召唤。我想回去做学术研究，以更多地了解人们如何处理这样的事情。我很快就被意义研究和叙事研究吸引，作为寻找意义的一种方式。这让我非常深刻地参与了英雄之旅的工作。我觉得我被召唤去研究它。特别是关于干预部分，不仅仅是说，你知道，有意义是件好事，有些人
have more or less, but actually using my research to help people find more meaning in their lives or maybe they're at work. And that also shows up in my teaching as well. I teach in a business school. I teach organizational behavior, so topics like leadership and teamwork and really important things. But I also love to infuse in my class work
有更多或更少，而是实际上利用我的研究来帮助人们在他们的生活中或在工作中找到更多的意义。这也体现在我的教学中。我在商学院教书。我教组织行为学，所以像领导力和团队合作这样的话题，以及非常重要的事情。但我也喜欢在我的课堂作业中注入
this idea of meaning in life is really important. Finding meaning in your work is something that is not just a nice to have, but is really important. And I like being there for students at a really formative time in their lives where they're facing a lot of pressures to get that investment banking job
这种生活意义非常重要的想法。在工作中找到意义不仅仅是一件好事，而且是非常重要的。我喜欢在学生们生命中非常重要的时期陪伴他们，那时他们面临着巨大的压力去获得那份投资银行的工作
or to get that consulting gig. And I like being there to say, yes, those are important. Yes, those are great goals. But also, you should think about broader sense of impact in terms of your lives. So both in terms of my research and my teaching, I sort of transformed into someone who might have been able to help me along when I was in those same shoes a few years ago. In your very first semester of teaching band, you found a way to have your own hero's journey leave a legacy in the lives of your students.
或者获得那份咨询工作。我喜欢在那里说，是的，这些很重要。是的，这些都是伟大的目标。但同时，你也应该考虑在你的生活中产生更广泛的影响。所以无论是在我的研究还是教学方面，我都转变成为一个可能在几年前我处于同样境地时能够帮助我的人。在你教书的第一个学期，本，你找到了一种方法，让你自己的英雄之旅在学生的生活中留下遗产。
Tell me what happened. Yes, so this is one of those moments where looking back on it, it felt like fate or it felt like, you know, the natural end of the hero's journey that I now realize. And so what happened was I actually had not one, but two students in my first semester whose parents or who one of their parents passed away. So one, their parent had just passed away right before this semester
告诉我发生了什么。是的，这是那些回想起来感觉像是命运，或者感觉像是，你知道，我现在意识到的英雄之旅的自然结局的时刻之一。所以发生的事情是我实际上在第一个学期不仅有一个，而是有两个学生，他们的父母或者其中一位父母去世了。所以一个，他们的父母就在学期前刚刚去世
and one, one of their parents had passed away during the semester. And as you can imagine, based on my past experiences, I felt a profound sense of duty to try to help these students however I could. And while I wasn't able to fix what had happened to them as I had been through that same experience, I was able to pull on both my research and my own life experiences to try to point them towards the ideas of meaning, the ideas of well-being, the ideas of how do they march forward that I think I would have really appreciated it at the time. And in fact, in my last class day, I decided to have my students do the hero's journey intervention. And it was a pretty emotional experience for me. I actually found myself tearing up as I was teaching these students and looking at these two students in particular and telling them my own personal hero's journey that we've kind of discussed today. And seeing the wave of recognitions over them was really a profound way of giving back that I didn't anticipate being able to make so early. And maybe a lot of this legacy is in my own mind, which is still very memorable to myself. But it's something that I'm really proud of
一个，他们的父母在学期中去世了。正如你可以想象的那样，基于我过去的经历，我感到一种深刻的责任感，要尽我所能帮助这些学生。虽然我无法修复发生在他们身上的事情，就像我经历过同样的经历一样，但我能够利用我的研究和我自己的生活经历，试图引导他们走向意义、幸福感、他们如何前进的想法，我认为我在当时会非常感激这些。事实上，在我的最后一天课上，我决定让我的学生进行英雄之旅的干预。对我来说，这是一次非常感人的经历。我在教这些学生时，看着这两个学生，并告诉他们我们今天讨论过的我自己的个人英雄之旅，我发现自己热泪盈眶。看到他们脸上的认同感，这真是一种我没预料到能这么早就能做出的深刻的回馈方式。也许这种遗产很大程度上是在我自己的脑海中，这对我自己来说仍然非常难忘。但我真的很自豪
that I was there and that I was able to use all of the transformation, all of the challenges I had faced in my personal and my professional life to try to make a difference in these students beyond just teaching them concepts in the classroom. And this is very much like what we talked about. Frodo Baggins returns to the Shire and is now able to use the personal transformation that he has experienced to help the people around him. This was very much. my small way of returning back to the Shire and trying to give back and help, you know, kick people out the door in a very positive way of you're dealing with this very difficult experience, but, you know, life will go on. And here's some tools and some insights from my challenge
我当时在那里，我能够利用我在个人和职业生活中面临的所有转变、所有挑战，试图在课堂上教授概念之外，对这些学生产生影响。这非常像我们谈论的。弗罗多·巴金斯回到了夏尔，现在能够利用他所经历的个人转变来帮助他周围的人。这非常像。我回到夏尔的小方式，试图回馈并帮助，你知道，以一种非常积极的方式把人们踢出门外，你正在处理这种非常困难的经历，但是，你知道，生活还会继续。这里有一些来自我的挑战的工具和见解
and transformation that maybe would be helpful for them. Some time ago, we heard from a listener named Lisbeth, who was about to embark on a journey. It wasn't a hero's journey, but one that many of us dread. In 2018, Leesbeth was on the hunt for a new apartment. There was just one complication. I had a partner who was moving across country
和转变，也许对他们会有帮助。前段时间，我们收到了一位名叫莉斯贝斯的听众的来信，她即将踏上一段旅程。这不是英雄之旅，而是我们许多人所恐惧的旅程。2018年，莉斯贝斯正在寻找一套新公寓。只有一个复杂的情况。我有一个伴侣要搬到全国各地
to live with me, and she had three dogs and multiple cats, and I had cats, too. But it wasn't just that. One of the dogs was a pit bull. It is very hard to find someone who will rent to you. One, if you have more than one pet, but
和我住在一起，她有三只狗和多只猫，我也有猫。但这不仅仅是这样。其中一只狗是比特犬。很难找到愿意租给你的人。第一，如果你有不止一只宠物，但是
two, if one of those pets is a pit bull. After looking at more than 20 apartments, not a single one came through. Finally, one couple said yes. Leesbeth knew why they said yes. We finally found this gay couple, that that is the reason that they took a chance on us. It was our connection in the LGBTQ plus group. The apartment search was one of many times when Leesbeth felt supported by the queer community. I came out in college, so that's when.
第二，如果其中一只宠物是比特犬。在看了20多套公寓后，没有一套成功。最后，一对夫妇答应了。莉斯贝斯知道他们为什么答应。我们终于找到了这对同性恋夫妇，这就是他们冒险选择我们的原因。这是我们在LGBTQ+群体中的联系。公寓搜索是莉斯贝斯感到被酷儿社区支持的多次经历之一。我在大学时出柜，所以那是
I joined the LGBTQ plus group. And I know there are a lot of parents who don't want their kids to come out. They think it's going to be such a hard life. They're so scared. But I've had the opposite experience. I've held so much belonging and connection from being part of that group. I mean, when one queer person passes another queer person, we look at each other and smile with this like knowing, like, yeah, we're in the same group. And it's such a good feeling. Such a good feeling. Think back to the last time you experienced something like this. Maybe you were at a work conference chatting with people in your particular field.
我加入了LGBTQ+小组。我知道有很多父母不希望他们的孩子出柜。他们认为这会是如此艰难的生活。他们太害怕了。但我有相反的经历。我从成为那个群体的一部分中获得了如此多的归属感和联系。我的意思是，当一个酷儿遇到另一个酷儿时，我们看着对方，带着这种心照不宣的微笑，就像，是的，我们在同一个群体中。这是一种很好的感觉。如此好的感觉。回想一下你最后一次经历这样的事情。也许你在一个工作会议上与你特定领域的人聊天。
Or at the grocery store, where you laughed with a stranger because you were both wearing the same band's t-shirt. Or perhaps you were thousands of miles from home in a foreign country, and someone came up to you and started speaking in your native tongue. This happened to researcher J. Van Baville when he was a teenager. He was in Italy, and a girl about his age came up to him and started speaking in English. She'd seen a maple leaf on his sweater and recognized a fellow Canadian. Even when these moments are fleeting, a glance of recognition, a chat in a McDonald's in Italy, they give us a boost. We sense this other person is like us. Maybe they share the same interests or a similar past.
或者在杂货店，你和一个陌生人一起笑，因为你们都穿着同一个乐队的T恤。或者也许你离家数千英里在国外，有人走过来开始用你的母语和你说话。研究员J.范·巴维尔在青少年时期就发生过这种情况。他在意大利，一个和他年龄相仿的女孩走过来开始用英语和他说话。她看到了他毛衣上的枫叶，认出了一个同胞加拿大人。即使这些时刻是短暂的，一个认出的眼神，在意大利麦当劳的一次聊天，它们给了我们一个提升。我们感觉到这个人就像我们一样。也许他们有相同的兴趣或相似的过去。
Maybe they see the world as we do. The opposite also holds true. When we interact with people from a different group, we feel some distance from them. We wonder if they have different interests, different values, different priorities. Our minds do this so quickly that we're not aware of how we're putting people into boxes, us and them. When we come back, the psychology of group identities and how group dynamics shape our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
也许他们像我们一样看待世界。反之亦然。当我们与来自不同群体的人互动时，我们感到与他们有一些距离。我们想知道他们是否有不同的兴趣、不同的价值观、不同的优先事项。我们的大脑如此迅速地做到这一点，以至于我们没有意识到我们是如何把人放进盒子里，我们和他们。当我们回来时，群体认同的心理学以及群体动态如何塑造我们的生活。你正在收听Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
At New York University, psychologist Jay Van Bavel studies the power of group identities. Along with Dominic Packer, he is the author of the power of us, harnessing our shared identities to improve performance, increase cooperation,
在纽约大学，心理学家杰伊·范·巴维尔研究群体认同的力量。他与多米尼克·帕克合著了《我们的力量：利用我们的共同身份来提高表现、增加合作》，
and promote social harmony. Jay was a guest on a previous Hidden Brain episode. It was titled Group Think. Today, he joins us to respond to listener questions and comments about his work. Jay Van Bavel, welcome back to you. hidden brain. Thank you so much for having me again. Jay, you found that the groups we belong to
并促进社会和谐。杰伊是之前Hidden Brain节目的一位嘉宾。节目名为“群体思维”。今天，他加入我们，回应听众关于他工作的提问和评论。杰伊·范·巴维尔，欢迎回到Hidden Brain。非常感谢你再次邀请我。杰伊，你发现我们所属的群体
shape everything from how we vote to the beer that we drink. Paint me a picture of the range of ways in which our groups shape who we are? The best way of thinking about it is that our groups are part of our identity, that we think of ourselves sometimes as individuals, but much of the time we think of ourselves as part of a group, as part of a fan of a sports team or in terms of our national identity, or even in terms of the role we have at our work. And once we think about ourselves through that lens, it changes how we interpret everything in our environment, from the people around us to our goals, to the food that we taste. So in other words, when I say that I'm a man, for example, in some ways, that is a group
塑造了一切，从我们如何投票到我们喝的啤酒。给我描绘一下我们的群体塑造我们是谁的各种方式？思考它的最好方式是，我们的群体是我们身份的一部分，我们有时认为自己是个人，但大部分时间我们认为自己是群体的一部分，作为运动队的粉丝，或者就我们的国家认同而言，甚至就我们在工作中扮演的角色而言。一旦我们通过那个镜头思考自己，它就会改变我们解释环境中一切的方式，从我们周围的人到我们的目标，再到我们品尝的食物。所以换句话说，当我例如说我是一个男人时，在某些方面，那是一个群体
identity. In fact, I'm pointing to something where I'm a part of a very large group of people. Yeah. And this can be good. It can help you build an affinity and solidarity with other men. it can also be bad if it leads to discrimination against women. Why do you think it is that the groups we belong to influence us so deeply, Jay? The reason is because it's fundamentally who we are.
认同。事实上，我指的是我是一个非常庞大的群体的一部分。是的。这可能是好的。它可以帮助你建立与其他男人的亲和力和团结。如果它导致对女性的歧视，它也可能是坏的。你认为为什么我们所属的群体对我们影响如此深远，杰伊？原因是因为这从根本上就是我们是谁。
I like to think of it as something that's baked into our DNA. Humans evolved in small groups, and the only way that we were able to survive and spread around the earth is by cooperating with one another. And the individuals and those groups who got kicked out of the group didn't survive and didn't pass on our genes. We are the descendants of people who manage to fit in. And after generation and generation of generation of people who manage to do that,
我喜欢把它看作是刻在我们DNA里的东西。人类在小群体中进化，我们能够生存并传播到地球各地的唯一方式就是相互合作。那些被踢出群体的个人和群体没有生存下来，也没有传递我们的基因。我们是那些设法融入的人的后代。经过一代又一代设法做到这一点的人，
we are groupish creatures. You and other researchers have found that groups can shape us in big ways, but they also shape us in subtle ways down to even our sensory perceptions? Yes. We've run studies where we find that, for example, if you go into Switzerland, where chocolate is a big part of their national identity, and a source of national pride, if you make them think about themselves in terms of their Swiss identity,
我们是群体性生物。你和其他研究人员发现，群体可以以巨大的方式塑造我们，但它们也以微妙的方式塑造我们，甚至深入到我们的感官知觉？是的。我们进行过研究，发现例如，如果你去瑞士，巧克力是他们国家认同的重要组成部分，也是民族自豪感的来源，如果你让他们从瑞士认同的角度思考自己，
they smell chocolate as more intense than when they're just thinking about themselves through a different identity. Wow. Let's talk about some of the factors that bind us together. We heard from a listener named Evelyn. She's a film teacher,
他们闻到的巧克力比他们只是通过不同的身份思考自己时更强烈。哇。让我们谈谈一些将我们联系在一起的因素。我们收到了一位名叫伊芙琳的听众的来信。她是一位电影老师，
and she organized a summit to make films that brought together young people from around the world. The kids came from 26 countries. Evelyn writes, making films about serious subjects like climate change, discrimination, and women's rights, was the shared purpose that brought them together. Talk about how a sense of shared purpose, Jay, can bind people together. I feel like we see examples of this all through history.
她组织了一次峰会，制作了将世界各地的年轻人聚集在一起的电影。孩子们来自26个国家。伊芙琳写道，制作关于气候变化、歧视和妇女权利等严肃主题的电影，是将他们聚集在一起的共同目标。谈谈共同目标感，杰伊，如何将人们联系在一起。我觉得我们在整个历史中都看到了这样的例子。
Yeah, I think that 75 years of research on this topic has taught us one thing. It's that when people have a goal that pulls them together, where they all have to contribute, is one of the most powerful ways of binding people together. And it can pull together people who are normally in groups in conflict. Suddenly they're motivated to cooperate and try to accomplish something that's really important to all of them. And so climate change is a great example of that. It motivates and inspires all kinds of people from around the world to care about a real
是的，我认为关于这个主题的75年研究教会了我们一件事。那就是当人们有一个将他们聚集在一起的目标，他们都必须做出贡献时，这是将人们联系在一起的最强大的方式之一。它可以将通常处于冲突群体中的人们聚集在一起。突然间，他们有了合作的动力，并试图完成对他们所有人来说都非常重要的事情。所以气候变化就是一个很好的例子。它激励和启发了世界各地各种各样的人去关心一个真正
important issue. Now, groups can also come together around shared pain. A listener named Edith is a clinical psychologist in Miami. she worked with survivors and family members of people who died in the collapse of the surfside condominium in 2021. Through meetings of groups every day for almost a month, we were able to get people together of all different kinds of religions, genders, countries of origin, and races and beliefs to get together and really come together as a family, overcoming many, many differences that maybe in
重要的问题。现在，群体也可以围绕共同的痛苦聚集在一起。一位名叫伊迪丝的听众是迈阿密的临床心理学家。她与2021年瑟夫赛德公寓倒塌事故中遇难者的幸存者和家属一起工作。通过近一个月每天的群体会议，我们能够让各种宗教、性别、原籍国、种族和信仰的人聚集在一起，真正像一家人一样走到一起，克服了许多在
another circumstance they would not be able to overcome. So we talked a second ago about the role of shared purpose. Can you also talk about the role of shared pain? Yes, one of the most powerful ways to bind people together is a shared experience that requires them to support one another. And so this can happen under threat when you feel like your group is being attacked. And it can happen under a disaster traumatic experience like the one that happened in Miami. And this is part of, again, human nature. We tend to think of humans as having this reaction to stress as fight or flight. But research has found that we also engage in what's called tending and befriending.
另一种情况下他们可能无法克服的差异。所以我们刚才谈到了共同目标的作用。你也能谈谈共同痛苦的作用吗？是的，将人们联系在一起的最强大的方式之一是需要他们相互支持的共同经历。所以这可以在威胁下发生，当你觉得你的群体受到攻击时。它可以在像迈阿密发生的那样的灾难性创伤经历下发生。这再次是人性的一部分。我们倾向于认为人类对压力的反应是战斗或逃跑。但研究发现，我们也从事所谓的“照顾和结交”。
That under stress, two of the most powerful ways of coping are to work together and build support networks and relationships and tending to one another, to help one another get through it. I mean, this might be why when you think about people who are in military outfits, for example, they may have served in combat 30 years ago, 50 years ago, 70 years ago, and they still think about the buddy in the trench next to them from all those years back as being one of the closest people to them in their entire lives. Yeah. And I've actually heard that people in the military, why they're willing to throw themselves on a grenade or jump out of a trench and defend their fellow military members is not necessarily even because they care about the belief system
在压力下，应对的最强大方式之一是共同努力，建立支持网络和关系，并相互照顾，帮助彼此度过难关。我的意思是，这可能就是为什么当你想到那些在军队里的人时，例如，他们可能在30年前、50年前、70年前服过役，他们仍然认为多年前在他们旁边的战壕里的伙伴是他们一生中最亲近的人之一。是的。我实际上听说过，军队里的人，他们为什么愿意扑向手榴弹或跳出战壕保卫他们的战友，甚至不一定是因为他们关心信仰体系
of their country, but they're there to defend the immediate group of people who are in the trenches with them. Their bonds are incredibly well-connected and powerful. And the military does lots of things like marching and chanting in unison, as well as their experiences in war that bind them together. I'm wondering if it's also the case that when people go through some shared suffering together, in some ways they have an understanding of the world that is different than people who have not been through that terrible thing.
他们的国家，但他们是为了保卫与他们一起在战壕里的直接群体。他们的纽带联系极其紧密且强大。军队做了很多事情，比如齐步走和齐声高喊，以及他们在战争中的经历，这些都将他们联系在一起。我想知道，当人们一起经历某种共同的苦难时，在某些方面他们是否对世界有一种不同于那些没有经历过那件可怕事情的人的理解。
So if you've gone through a natural disaster, for example, and you know what that was like, you know, you can try and explain it to people who weren't there, but it's not the same as someone who actually was there with you while it was happening. Yes. One of a core part of any group is having a shared sense of. reality. And so sometimes we rally around a shared experience. A part of it is because other people from the outside might not understand what it's like to go through that and experience it and suffer through it. The other thing that groups do is create a shared sense of reality. In this case,
所以如果你经历过自然灾害，例如，你知道那是什么感觉，你知道，你可以尝试向那些不在那里的人解释，但这与那些在事情发生时和你在一起的人是不一样的。是的。任何群体的核心部分都是拥有共同的现实感。所以有时我们围绕共同的经历团结起来。部分原因是外部的人可能不理解经历、体验和忍受那种痛苦是什么感觉。群体所做的另一件事是创造共同的现实感。在这种情况下，
they create a sense of meaning and purpose that helps them get past the pain and find a way forward in their lives. Now, there's a flip side to the warmth and connection that group identities can bring us. A listener Rebecca grew up in the Midwest. She had a question about group dynamics when it comes to tightly knit religious and cultural communities. I noticed when I was growing up and in high school many years ago that it was a big deal if a young person moved away from the community to the point that I was told that they
他们创造了一种意义和目标感，帮助他们克服痛苦，找到在生活中前进的方式。现在，群体认同带给我们的温暖和联系也有另一面。一位听众丽贝卡在中西部长大。她对紧密联系的宗教和文化社区的群体动态有一个疑问。我注意到当我长大并在多年前上高中时，如果一个年轻人离开社区，这是一件大事，以至于我被告知他们
would have a ceremonial funeral for that person if they did not come back within some period of time. I got to believe that there's a group dynamic at play there that's attracted some research, and I'm curious what drives that, because these are family members, often parents and siblings. Thank you. So, J, the story shows the power of religion to bind some people together and to exclude others. And I think what I hear Rebecca asking is how a parent can set aside family bonds with a son or a daughter in favor of religious ties? Yeah, the point. The point here is really profound, which is that we think of our family and these people share our DNA. They're like as close to us as possible.
如果那个人在一段时间内没有回来，就会为他举行仪式性的葬礼。我相信这其中存在一种群体动力，并吸引了一些研究，我很好奇是什么驱动了这种动力，因为这些人是家庭成员，通常是父母和兄弟姐妹。谢谢。那么，J，这个故事展示了宗教将一些人团结在一起并排斥其他人的力量。我想我听到丽贝卡问的是，父母怎么能为了宗教纽带而抛弃与儿子或女儿的家庭纽带？是的，重点。这里的重点非常深刻，那就是我们认为我们的家庭和这些人分享我们的DNA。他们就像是我们尽可能亲近的人。
And yet these other group identities can become more important. And what's happening in these situations is something that could normally be positive, which is you're part of a religious community that looks out for one another, cares for one another, provides support and meaning. But in this case, if you're getting people to turn against their own family members and have a funeral when they're gone, what that starts to look like is cult psychology. And we have a chapter of this about cult psychology in our book.
然而，这些其他的群体认同可能会变得更加重要。在这些情况下发生的事情，本来可能是积极的，即你是一个宗教团体的一部分，大家互相照顾、关心，提供支持和意义。但在这种情况下，如果你让人们背叛自己的家庭成员，并在他们离开时举行葬礼，这看起来就像是邪教心理。我们的书中有一章专门讨论邪教心理。
And when people are part of a cultish type of group, and this can happen in religious communities, it can happen at work. The example of a cult that we studied in organizations was Enron, which was a massive energy company that went bankrupt because they had a cult-like mentality. And in those environments, you create social norms that are very unhealthy. People, when they're part of a group, they want to be good group members and belong.
当人们成为邪教类团体的一部分时，这种情况可能发生在宗教团体中，也可能发生在工作中。我们在组织中研究的一个邪教例子是安然公司，这是一家大型能源公司，因为他们有一种邪教心态而破产。在这些环境中，你创造了非常不健康的社会规范。人们在成为群体的一部分时，他们希望成为好的群体成员并获得归属感。
And so they look to see what the norms are in the community of fellow group members and they follow them. And so what you're seeing in this example is that the norm is to treat anybody who leaves as dead to them. In some traditional religious communities, they also engage in what's called shunning. If you leave the group, your family is not allowed to talk to you anymore, ever again. And so these are where the norms get very strong and can lead to very negative relationships with people who would otherwise be the closest to you, the ones you'd care about and love and would be there for you as well. Do you think there's a bright line or a blurry line between, you know, let's say fans of a sports team and they're devoted to the sports team and they have antagonism to the fans of other sports teams and what you're describing as a cult? Yeah. So I think sports are a really good example because I'm a big sports fan.
所以他们会观察群体成员中的规范是什么，并遵循它们。在这个例子中，你所看到的是，规范是将任何离开的人视为死人。在一些传统宗教社区中，他们还会进行所谓的“排斥”。如果你离开这个群体，你的家人就不再被允许与你交谈，永远不再。这就是规范变得非常强大，并可能导致与本应最亲近的人——那些你关心、爱护并会支持你的人——产生非常负面的关系的地方。你认为在体育迷（他们忠于球队并对其他球队的球迷有敌意）和你所描述的邪教之间，有一条清晰的界限还是模糊的界限？是的。所以我认为体育是一个很好的例子，因为我是一个超级体育迷。
I've been to lots of football games, hockey games, baseball games. And you can walk into a stadium with 100,000 other people chanting and covered in the colors of the team. And it can feel like actually a hostile environment. But in almost none of the stadiums I've ever been to has anything ever broken out into actual conflict. And again, the reason here is because of norms. because when you go to a professional football game or baseball game, the norm is that everybody's there to cheer and you're allowed to cheer for the opposite team
我参加过很多足球比赛、曲棍球比赛、棒球比赛。你可以走进一个有10万人的体育场，大家都在高呼，身上覆盖着球队的颜色。这看起来确实像是一个充满敌意的环境。但在我去过的几乎所有体育场里，从来没有发生过真正的冲突。同样，这里的原因是规范。因为当你去参加职业足球比赛或棒球比赛时，规范是每个人都在那里欢呼，而且你被允许为对方球队欢呼。
and people will maybe give you a hard time or tease you, but it will never cross a line. And they have people there to enforce the norms, you know, the ushers security that's now they scan you when you come in to make sure you're not a risk to anybody and bringing in anything dangerous. And when you do that, you can actually have incredible numbers of people
人们可能会让你难堪或取笑你，但它永远不会越界。他们有工作人员在那里执行规范，你知道，引座员、安保人员，现在他们会在你进入时扫描你，以确保你不会对任何人构成风险，也不会带入任何危险物品。当你这样做时，你实际上可以拥有数量惊人的人。
all chanting and cheering and feeling all of the intense emotions associated with groupishness without spilling over into the violence that you see in normal intergroup conflict. When we come back, why we can sometimes feel part of a group one day, but not the next. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In his book, Bowling Alone, the political scientist Robert Putnam, that since the 1950s, Americans were engaging less with social groups. Gone were many of the bowling leagues, civic organizations, and religious groups
所有人都在高呼、欢呼，并感受到与群体性相关的所有强烈情绪，而不会演变成你在正常的群体间冲突中看到的那种暴力。当我们回来时，为什么我们有时会觉得一天是群体的一部分，而第二天却不是。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在他的书《独自打保龄球》中，政治学家罗伯特·普特南指出，自20世纪50年代以来，美国人参与社会团体的程度在降低。许多保龄球联盟、公民组织和宗教团体已经消失了。
that bonded us with neighbors and friends. Instead, we watched TV by ourselves or buried our faces in our phones. But at New York University, J. Van Bavel argues that group identities, while changing, remain a central part of who we are. Jay, one thing we talked about in our last conversation was sports fandom, and we've talked a little bit about it today as well. We received an email from a listener named Lois, who writes, having had polio as a child, I have lived over 70 years with a partially paralyzed right leg. Sports teams have not been a part of my life, but musical groups
那些将我们与邻居和朋友联系在一起的纽带。相反，我们独自看电视或埋头于手机。但在纽约大学，J·范·巴贝尔认为，群体认同虽然在变化，但仍然是我们身份的核心部分。杰伊，我们在上次谈话中谈到的一件事是体育迷，今天我们也谈到了一点。我们收到了一位名叫洛伊斯的听众的电子邮件，她写道，作为一名儿时患过小儿麻痹症的人，我带着部分瘫痪的右腿生活了70多年。体育队不是我生活的一部分，但音乐团体。
have been. I'm quite sure you would find the closest groups with the strongest interpersonal bonds are those involved with performing music. I'll expand on what Lois is saying here, Jay, to include all performing arts, theater, comedy, dance, can being part of an artistic troupe help to bring people together? That is something I think that's really important to point out, is that groups can form around all kinds of shared interests, certainly around people who are part of a symphony or a musical group, part of other creative endeavors. And often those connections are really profound. And there's lots of good reasons for it. So there's research showing that when people listen to music together, it actually binds them and generates a shared identity.
却是。我很确定你会发现，拥有最强人际纽带的亲密群体是那些参与表演音乐的人。杰伊，我会扩展洛伊斯在这里所说的内容，包括所有的表演艺术、戏剧、喜剧、舞蹈，成为艺术团的一部分能帮助人们团结在一起吗？我认为这一点非常重要，即群体可以围绕各种共同利益形成，当然也包括那些交响乐团或音乐团体的成员，以及其他创造性努力的参与者。这些联系通常非常深刻。而且有很多充分的理由。研究表明，当人们一起听音乐时，它实际上将他们联系在一起并产生了一种共同的身份。
This is in part why concerts can be really powerful emotional experiences because everybody's dancing and moving and just immersed in the music. And certainly other creative endeavors where you're part of a community where you get a sense of belonging and a sense of distinctiveness are really powerful for driving really strong group identities. And so for artists, a lot of times they are kind of the rebel. of society. They're trying new things. They're creative and different from mainstream society. And so that actually can be something that makes them feel special to be part of something that's
这在一定程度上是音乐会之所以能成为非常强大的情感体验的原因，因为每个人都在跳舞、移动，并沉浸在音乐中。当然，其他创造性的努力，当你成为一个社区的一部分，获得归属感和独特性感时，对于驱动非常强大的群体认同也非常有效。因此，对于艺术家来说，他们很多时候是社会的“叛逆者”。他们尝试新事物。他们富有创造力，与主流社会不同。因此，这实际上可以让他们感到特别，因为他们是某种事物的一部分，而这种事物。
different from the way everybody else is approaching and thinking about life. We received a message from listener Christina about the role of place in shaping identity. I was reflecting on how group identity has shaped my life. And at first, it was really difficult to come up with examples. And then I stopped for just a moment to think about my biggest identity. And one of those is being a Houstonian, someone born and raised in Houston, Texas. So people often have really strong affinities with the place that they identify as home, Jay. What I find so fascinating about this is a place is just, you know, a place. It's the land, the streets and buildings. Why do you think our hometowns exert the force on us that they do?
与其他人对待和思考生活的方式不同。我们收到了听众克里斯蒂娜关于地点在塑造身份中的作用的信息。我一直在反思群体认同是如何塑造我的生活的。起初，很难想出例子。然后我停下来思考了一下我最大的身份。其中之一是作为休斯顿人，一个在德克萨斯州休斯顿出生和长大的人。所以人们通常对自己认同为家的地方有很强的亲和力，杰伊。我发现这非常迷人的一点是，一个地方只是，你知道，一个地方。它是土地、街道和建筑物。你认为为什么我们的家乡会对我们产生这样的影响？
Place is an incredibly powerful way that we find and connect with other people, build shared memories, have a sense of purpose. And there's lots of symbols associated with place that signal that were special. So I live in New York City, and I've lived here for last 16 years. And I've developed an identity as a New Yorker, even though I didn't move here until I was already 30 years old. And in New York, there's a very strong identity. I've actually heard that even having the phone number 212 at the start of your phone number is something that New Yorkers value. and really don't want to lose once they get it because it's a powerful signal that you're a true New Yorker.
地点是我们寻找并与他人联系、建立共同记忆、拥有目标感的一种极其强大的方式。而且有很多与地点相关的符号，标志着我们是特别的。我住在纽约市，我已经在这里住了16年了。我已经发展出了一种纽约人的身份，尽管我直到30岁才搬到这里。在纽约，有一种非常强烈的身份认同。我甚至听说，即使在电话号码开头有212这个区号，也是纽约人所珍视的。一旦拥有，他们真的不想失去，因为它是一个强大的信号，表明你是一个真正的纽约人。
But I will say this. I was just actually last night planning my high school reunion with my friends because I grew up in a small town called Fox Creek, 2,000 people in rural, northern Alberta and Canada. And we still talk, you know, it's now 30 years since our graduation. And we have a shared sense of identity from that place, experiences, memories, and connections that will still draw us together that will pull people together from multiple countries to get together to revisit
但我会说这一点。实际上就在昨晚，我还在和朋友们计划我的高中同学聚会，因为我在加拿大阿尔伯塔省北部农村一个叫福克斯克里克的小镇长大，那里有2000人。我们仍然在交谈，你知道，距离我们毕业已经30年了。我们对那个地方有一种共同的身份感、经历、记忆和联系，这些仍然会将我们吸引在一起，将来自多个国家的人们拉到一起，重温。
those and remember them and share them. So place is incredibly important to people, whether it's a country, a state, a town or a city, or even your local community. Some communities have a really strong identity where they have like group barbecues and activities that are just community focused. So this can happen at all kinds of place. So Christina, as we heard, is from Houston. But besides identifying with Houston, she took care to mention that she does not identify with another city. Here she is again. And a big part of that identity is not only love for our city and our sports teams, but along with that comes a dislike for the city of Dallas, our rival in many things,
那些记忆并分享它们。所以地点对人们来说极其重要，无论是国家、州、城镇还是城市，甚至是你的当地社区。有些社区有非常强烈的身份认同，他们有类似集体烧烤和以社区为中心的活动。所以这可以在各种地方发生。所以克里斯蒂娜，正如我们所听到的，来自休斯顿。但除了认同休斯顿之外，她还特意提到她不认同另一个城市。她又来了。这种身份认同的很大一部分不仅是对我们城市和运动队的爱，而且随之而来的是对达拉斯市的厌恶，这是我们在许多事情上的竞争对手。
not only in business, but in sports. And I was like, well, that hasn't really affected my life until I stopped for just another moment and realized I actually turned down a job offer that I really wanted because of the simple fact that it was in Dallas. And as a Houstonian, that was just so unpalatable to me. So Jay, you found that these days much of our connection to our groups is actually motivated by our animosity toward outside groups. Say more about this idea. Yeah, a core part of identity is a sense of us and them. Not only is there a sense of who we are, but who we are not.
不仅在商业上，而且在体育上。我当时想，好吧，这并没有真正影响我的生活，直到我停下来又想了一会儿，意识到我实际上拒绝了一份我非常想要的工作，仅仅因为它在达拉斯。作为一名休斯顿人，这对我来说太令人难以接受了。所以杰伊，你发现这些天我们与群体的许多联系实际上是由我们对外部群体的敌意所驱动的。多说说这个想法。是的，身份的核心部分是“我们”和“他们”的感觉。不仅有我们是谁的感觉，还有我们不是谁的感觉。
There's a critical group boundary. And in the case where you have a rivalry, like between Houston and Dallas, it actually provides a very powerful motivating force for people to come together to compete with people in Dallas, whether it's sports or forms of civic pride. And that can actually be an incredible motivator. There are studies that have been done actually at NYU's business school about the power of arrival. That when we have a rival, it is actually one of the triggers that can really. bind us together and motivate us to do incredible things. And those things can be great things in America, I think, of the Cold War and the space race and the development of all the technology that came up from that competition.
有一个关键的群体边界。在像休斯顿和达拉斯之间存在竞争的情况下，它实际上为人们团结起来与达拉斯人竞争提供了一种非常强大的动力，无论是体育还是公民自豪感。这实际上可以成为一种令人难以置信的激励因素。纽约大学商学院实际上已经做过关于竞争对手力量的研究。当我们有一个竞争对手时，它实际上是真正能触发我们。将我们团结在一起并激励我们做不可思议的事情的触发因素之一。我认为在美国，这些事情可以是伟大的事情，想想冷战、太空竞赛以及由此产生的所有技术发展。
And then it can lead to negative things. If you really start to spill over this animosity into hatred, it can lead to violence, discrimination, and conflict. And so we have to be very mindful that it can be very useful to have healthy competition and healthy conflict, like the example of Houston versus Dallas and sports teams. But we have to be very mindful that there has to be a boundary where it doesn't spill over into those negative aspects of group identity. I'm wondering why many animosities around group identity are connected with people who are
然后它可能导致负面事情。如果你真的开始将这种敌意演变成仇恨，它可能导致暴力、歧视和冲突。因此，我们必须非常注意，拥有健康的竞争和健康的冲突是有益的，比如休斯顿对阵达拉斯和运动队的例子。但我们必须非常注意，必须有一个界限，使它不会演变成群体认同的那些负面方面。我想知道为什么许多围绕群体认同的敌意与那些。
quite similar to one another. So for 90% of the people on the planet, Dallas and Houston are both cities in Texas. They have so much in common. Why do you think it is that people from Houston and Dallas focus on what makes them dissimilar. Yeah, the classic term for this is called the narcissism of small differences that we actually often become obsessed with people who are very similar to us, in part because we're comparing ourselves to them. And so this can be where you're competitive with a good friend or an office mate because they seem the most relevant comparison to you. Now, that's different from
彼此非常相似的人有关。对于地球上90%的人来说，达拉斯和休斯顿都是德克萨斯州的城市。他们有很多共同点。你认为为什么休斯顿和达拉斯的人们会关注让他们不相似的地方？是的，这个经典的术语被称为“微小差异的自恋”，即我们实际上经常痴迷于与我们非常相似的人，部分原因是我们正在将自己与他们进行比较。所以这可能是你与好朋友或同事竞争的地方，因为他们看起来是你最相关的比较对象。现在，这与。
the way that most people think about conflict, where they think that we have conflict with the people who are most different from us, the people who have radically different belief systems or religions or come from different countries, different skin colors, different genders. But in most situations, it's actually the people who are similar to us because we see them as a relevant form of competition. I'm wondering if the same thing is true in politics. Republicans and Democrats in the United States feel like there are, you know, chasms separating them. But of course, so most people on the planet, that Republicans and Democrats within the U.S. are all Americans, and the distinction between them is probably small. Do you think this affects the way political polarization operates, Jay?
大多数人对冲突的看法不同，他们认为我们与最不同的人发生冲突，即那些拥有完全不同的信仰体系或宗教，或来自不同国家、不同肤色、不同性别的人。但在大多数情况下，实际上是与我们相似的人，因为我们将他们视为一种相关的竞争形式。我想知道政治中是否也是如此。美国的共和党人和民主党人觉得他们之间存在着鸿沟。但当然，对地球上的大多数人来说，美国境内的共和党人和民主党人都是美国人，他们之间的区别可能很小。你认为这会影响政治极化的运作方式吗，杰伊？
It is definitely part of the puzzle of polarization. I would say there's two pieces of the puzzle of polarization. One is that people do have genuine disagreements about some policies like health care or immigration. But on top of that, there is what we call affect of polarization, where it's just you really don't like a group. simply because they're part of another party, even if they agree with you on the actual policies. And so this leads to all kinds of real discrimination. And I will say part of it is exaggerated. If you actually measure what people believe, the average Democrat and average Republican
这绝对是极化难题的一部分。我想说极化难题有两个部分。一是人们确实对医疗保健或移民等一些政策存在真正的分歧。但除此之外，还有我们所说的“情感极化”，即你真的不喜欢一个群体。仅仅因为他们是另一个政党的一部分，即使他们在实际政策上与你达成一致。因此，这导致了各种真正的歧视。我会说部分原因是夸大的。如果你真的衡量人们相信什么，普通的民主党人和普通的共和党人。
aren't that far apart. But if you ask them what they think the other party believes, they imagine that people from the other party hate them way more than they do. They imagine that people in the other party are very different from them in terms of beliefs in terms of demographics. And so it creates a funny situation where they tend to avoid each other. They now move to different places
并没有那么大的差距。但如果你问他们认为对方政党相信什么，他们会想象对方政党的人比实际情况更讨厌他们。他们想象对方政党的人在信仰、人口统计方面与他们非常不同。因此，这创造了一个有趣的情况，他们倾向于互相回避。他们现在搬到不同的地方。
and communities and states. But if you actually put people from these different political parties in a conversation, they predict it will go badly and they're shocked when it goes as good as it does because their stereotypes are so negative
和社区以及州。但如果你真的让来自这些不同政党的人进行对话，他们预测情况会很糟糕，而当情况比他们预期的要好时，他们会感到震惊，因为他们的刻板印象太负面了。
and so distorted from reality that most people they're talking to once they're in the flesh and blood are actually much more personable and interesting and reasonable than they imagined. Yeah. One thing that I think many of us notice when it comes to group identity
并且与现实如此扭曲，以至于大多数他们交谈的人，一旦面对面，实际上比他们想象的要更平易近人、更有趣、更合理。是的。我认为我们许多人在群体认同方面注意到的一件事。
is that it can create very different conversations depending on who you're talking to. So, for example, you hear New Yorkers complain all the time about New York City. They'll say things like it's really dirty, there's trash everywhere, it's crowded, the housing is so expensive. But if you come in as an outsider and criticize New Yorkers,
是根据你交谈的对象，它可以创造非常不同的对话。例如，你经常听到纽约人抱怨纽约市。他们会说诸如“真的很脏，到处都是垃圾，很拥挤，住房太贵”之类的话。但如果你作为一个局外人进来批评纽约人。
will fight you. Yeah. There is something about the New York identity that is about complaining, about the smell, about the garbage, about all kinds of things. But it is also a source of pride. And there's actually a funny aspect of identity in that way. And again, this goes back to this optimal distinctiveness. New York feels different than every other city in America. And the things that make it distinctive are the things that can be really frustrating as you live here day to day. But they're also the things that make it special. And when someone from the outside, criticizes those things, you defend it.
他们会和你打架。是的。纽约身份中确实有一些关于抱怨的东西，关于气味，关于垃圾，关于各种各样的事情。但它也是一种自豪感的来源。而且这种身份认同确实有一个有趣的方面。同样，这回到了“最优独特性”。纽约感觉与美国其他任何城市都不同。使它与众不同的东西，也是你每天住在这里时可能感到非常沮丧的东西。但它们也是使它变得特别的东西。当来自外部的人批评这些东西时，你会捍卫它。
My favorite quote on this, I saw someone post this on social media. They said everybody complains that New York smells like urine. But they said the way you have to think about it is urine happens to smell like the greatest city on earth. You're thinking about it the wrong way. We heard from a listener named Karen. She has two daughters. And when they were younger, they played in a soccer league.
我最喜欢关于这个的引语，我看到有人在社交媒体上发布了这个。他们说每个人都抱怨纽约闻起来像尿。但他们说你必须思考的方式是，尿液恰好闻起来像地球上最伟大的城市。你思考它的方式不对。我们收到了听众凯伦的消息。她有两个女儿。当她们还小的时候，她们参加了一个足球联盟。
And she writes, the teams were chosen randomly, and every year you would sit with different people on different sides of the field based on what team your daughter was assigned to. So you could no longer sit with your friend whose daughter was on your daughter's team last year because they were now the enemy. It's interesting how one year you're cheering on a child because they are on your child's team and the next year you want them to lose. So it almost sounds, Jay, that, you know, Karen was taking part in a social science experiment, the way these soccer teams were constructed. but talk for a moment about how malleable group loyalties can be. So Karen's experience maps exactly onto my experience. When I was a kid, we'd play games of pick up hockey or pick up basketball or pick up football. And I had my one friend, Jaron, he and I were almost best friends.
她写道，球队是随机选择的，每年你都会根据你女儿被分配到的球队，坐在球场不同侧面的不同人身边。所以你不能再和你女儿去年在同一个队的朋友坐在一起了，因为他们现在是敌人。有趣的是，一年你为一个孩子欢呼，因为他们在你孩子的队里，而下一年你却希望他们输。所以听起来，杰伊，凯伦似乎是在参与一个社会科学实验，这些足球队是如何构建的。但谈谈群体忠诚度有多么容易改变。所以凯伦的经历完全映射了我的经历。当我还是个孩子的时候，我们会玩即兴曲棍球、即兴篮球或即兴足球。我有一个好朋友，杰伦，他和我是最好的朋友。
And if we flipped a coin and ended up on the same team, we got along famously. But if we were on the opposite team, by the end of the game, we'd be yelling and fighting with one another because we were both very competitive. And that inspired me actually to study group identity. And most of the research I started doing on this when I was a PhD student was bringing people into lab and flipping a coin and putting them on two teams. And what we found over and over and over again is just that simple random flip of a coin makes people identify with their own group and discriminate against the other group. They will give more resources to members of their own group.
如果我们掷硬币并最终在同一个队，我们相处得非常好。但如果我们是在对立的队，到比赛结束时，我们会互相大喊大叫和打架，因为我们都非常有竞争力。这实际上激励了我去研究群体认同。当我还是博士生时，我开始做的关于这个的大部分研究是将人们带进实验室，掷硬币并将他们分成两队。我们一次又一次发现的是，仅仅是那个简单的随机掷硬币就使人们认同自己的群体并歧视另一个群体。他们会给自己的群体成员更多的资源。
They see them as friends. They automatically trust them more and believe. what they say. And these are the things that happen, even if they don't have a chance to interact or even meet anybody in their own group, just knowing that they're part of the group is sufficient. And so this is actually called minimal groups because these effects have been found for 50 years over and over again. I actually think this is one of the most important findings in all of psychology that a flip of a coin changes our identities and radically changes how we see ourselves and how we treat other people in really deep, profound ways. And so,
他们视他们为朋友。他们自动更信任他们并相信。他们所说的话。即使他们没有机会互动或甚至没有见过自己群体中的任何人，仅仅知道他们是群体的一部分就足够了。所以这实际上被称为“最小群体”，因为这些效应在50年来被一次又一次地发现。我实际上认为这是心理学中最重要的发现之一，即掷硬币改变了我们的身份，并以非常深刻的方式彻底改变了我们如何看待自己以及我们如何对待他人。所以。
This is essentially what Karen's experiencing with her daughter and the soccer teams. This is a powerful psychological force. And it's something that it's easy to take for granted until you're in it. And you see what it does to you. But this is something that's important part of human social psychology. When we come back, what happens when you disagree with your group? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这本质上就是凯伦和她的女儿以及足球队所经历的。这是一种强大的心理力量。而且这是一种很容易被视为理所当然的事情，直到你身处其中。你看到它对你做了什么。但这确实是人类社会心理学的重要组成部分。当我们回来时，当你与你的群体发生分歧时会发生什么？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Psychologist J. Van Bavel studies how group identities can bridge religious, racial, and political divides. With Dominic Packer, he's the author of The Power of Us, harnessing our shared identities to improve performance, increase cooperation, and promote social harmony. As we've discussed, Jay, our group identities shape how we as individuals view the world, but being part of a group of people can be complicated. Maybe a political leader of your party or the coach of your sports team takes your group. group in a direction you might disagree with. Here is listener Miriam. I am a Jewish person. I identify very much with my group as a Jewish person, but I do not at all agree with what's happening in Israel right now in the conflict with Gaza. As a result, it makes me feel almost ashamed of my religion, and when it comes to the holidays, I'm very conflicted about
心理学家J·范·巴贝尔研究群体认同如何弥合宗教、种族和政治分歧。他与多米尼克·帕克合著了《我们的力量：利用我们的共同身份来提高绩效、增加合作并促进社会和谐》。正如我们所讨论的，杰伊，我们的群体认同塑造了我们作为个人如何看待世界，但成为一群人的一部分可能很复杂。也许你政党的政治领袖或你运动队的教练带领你的群体。群体走向一个你可能不同意的方向。这是听众米里亚姆。我是一个犹太人。我非常认同我作为犹太人的群体，但我完全不同意以色列目前在加沙冲突中发生的事情。结果，这让我对我的宗教感到几乎羞耻，当谈到节日时，我非常矛盾。
celebrating them. So I was just wondering, my question is, how does it affect people when the group identity that they've always had suddenly manifest something that they don't agree with or they feel uncomfortable with and they feel conflicted about it? What do you think, Jay? I mean, that's a really powerful question, Shanker. So what Miriam's talking about is the fact that you can feel pride when your group does well. Again, a national group winning a gold medal, your favorite sports team. But it can also be a source of shame. Or in this case, it sounds like she's feeling a lot of cognitive dissonance. Like she feels really identified at this group and very upset about where it's going. So when I hear stories like this, I think that one of the most important things about any group,
庆祝它们。所以我只是想知道，我的问题是，当人们一直拥有的群体认同突然表现出他们不同意或感到不舒服并感到矛盾的事情时，这对人们有什么影响？你觉得呢，杰伊？我的意思是，这是一个非常深刻的问题，尚卡尔。米里亚姆所说的是，当你的群体表现良好时，你可以感到自豪。同样，国家队赢得金牌，你最喜欢的运动队。但它也可能成为羞耻的来源。或者在这种情况下，听起来她感到了很多认知失调。就像她非常认同这个群体，但对它的发展方向感到非常不安。所以当我听到这样的故事时，我认为任何群体最重要的事情之一。
is to create healthy norms. And in this case, the norm that I think is really important in any healthy group is about dissent. The research on this, done by my co-author Dominic when we were in grad school, he wanted to understand why people speak up when they think their group is going wrong. And what he found was actually really counterintuitive. Many people have this notion that dissent happens when people don't like the group and want to leave it. But what actually happens is the opposite. it is often driven by people who really identify with the group and care about it and worry about
是创造健康的规范。在这种情况下，我认为在任何健康群体中都非常重要的规范是关于“异议”。关于这一点的研究，是由我的合著者多米尼克在我们读研究生时完成的，他想了解为什么人们在认为群体出错时会大声疾呼。他发现的情况实际上非常反直觉。许多人有这样一种观念，即异议发生在人们不喜欢这个群体并想离开它时。但实际上发生的是相反的情况。它通常是由那些真正认同群体、关心它并担心的人所驱动的。
where it's going and think that the group is going to be damaged if it continues down this direction. And so they speak up despite the fact that they know they're going to get pushback or social ostracism or punishment. Because I always just remind people, think of the terms we have for dissenters. You know, throughout history and how they're treated like heretics, how are they treated, traders, even devil's advocates. You go to a company and they'll say so-and-so is the devil's advocate. And I say, is there a meaner word you could come up for someone than devil's advocate? So like pause and think about what you're saying. And so what any group needs to do,
它要去向哪里，并认为如果它继续沿着这个方向发展，群体将会受到损害。所以他们大声疾呼，尽管他们知道他们会受到反击、社会排斥或惩罚。因为我总是提醒人们，想想我们对异议者的称呼。你知道，在整个历史上，他们是如何被对待的，像异端，他们是如何被对待的，叛徒，甚至是“魔鬼代言人”。你去一家公司，他们会说某某是“魔鬼代言人”。我说，你能为某人想出一个比“魔鬼代言人”更刻薄的词吗？所以停下来想想你在说什么。所以任何群体需要做的是。
whether this is a national group, part of a community, I often see this in organizations, to avoid that kind of cult mentality is to make sure that you make it safe for people to speak up in dissent, and part of it is understanding that the people who are doing it are doing it because they want to help the group and they're worried about it. And they think it's gone wrong. And so that is a fundamental norm that needs to be reinforced and ideally by leaders, because leaders can make it very hard to dissent if they punish dissenters, or they can make it easy by expressing how much they value them and how important it is. And in society, this is often through protest. This is like one of the most important signals of a healthy democracy is that
无论是国家群体、社区的一部分，我经常在组织中看到这一点，为了避免那种邪教心态，就是要确保你让人们安全地提出异议，部分原因是理解那些这样做的人这样做是因为他们想帮助群体，并且他们对此感到担忧。他们认为它出错了。所以这是一个需要被强化的基本规范，理想情况下是由领导者来强化，因为如果领导者惩罚异议者，他们会使异议变得非常困难，或者他们可以通过表达他们有多么重视他们以及它有多么重要来使它变得容易。在社会中，这通常是通过抗议。这是健康民主国家最重要的信号之一。
people can peacefully protest. So this is like a signal that we're healthy in our society if we can do this, that we can speak up. I've been to countries around the world where I talk openly of my criticisms of my home country and people's eyes get wide because they would never feel safe doing that in their own country. And so this is something that is really critical in any group that you're part of is to understand the dissenters are often the people who care the most. And they're speaking up because they're concerned and giving them a platform. and hearing them out, even if you don't agree with them,
人们可以和平抗议。所以这就像一个信号，表明如果我们能做到这一点，我们的社会就是健康的，我们可以大声疾呼。我去过世界各地的国家，在那里我公开谈论我对祖国的批评，人们的眼睛睁大了，因为他们永远不会觉得在自己的国家这样做是安全的。所以这是你所属的任何群体中非常关键的一点，即理解异议者往往是那些最关心的人。他们大声疾呼是因为他们很担心，并为他们提供一个平台。并听取他们的意见，即使你不同意他们。
at least taking them seriously and understanding they're doing it out of a position of care. You've done a lot of work looking at group identities in political context. Listener, Jacqueline, sent us a message about that. We definitely have a whole lot of tribalism going on in political parties, in families and friend groups, but certain groups are coded as bad or harmful. and I feel like we've collectively, we've just lost our collective culture.
至少认真对待他们，并理解他们这样做是出于关心。你在政治背景下做了大量关于群体认同的工作。听众杰奎琳给我们发了一条关于此的消息。我们在政党、家庭和朋友圈中确实存在大量的部落主义，但某些群体被编码为坏的或有害的。我觉得我们集体，我们只是失去了我们的集体文化。
What we're taught to do is stand on the other side of the stream and point a finger at somebody and hate them because of all of the ways that they're different from us. And what I've begun doing is seeking out people that don't agree with me and doing so from a place of curiosity, trying to understand them, and as a secondary to be understood, to listen more than I talk. So we talked earlier about how outgroup hate can be as or even more motivating than in-group love. And it's possible that maybe every generation feels that we are more divided than previous
我们被教导要做的是站在溪流的另一边，指着某人，因为他们与我们不同的所有方式而恨他们。而我开始做的是寻找那些不同意我的人，并从好奇心的角度出发，试图理解他们，其次是被理解，多听少说。所以我们之前谈到了群体外仇恨如何能像群体内爱一样，甚至比群体内爱更有动力。而且可能每一代人都觉得我们比前几代人更分裂。
generations. But what do you make of Jacqueline's point, Jay, about conflict between different political groups and also her approach to addressing it? So Jacqueline puts her finger on a feeling that many people right now in the United States have and many other countries. In the United States, as you said, this is a political divide in many cases. But hate can come from all kinds of angles. It can be driven by racial hatred. It can be driven by religious hatred. So I think we have to take it always very seriously that it is a dangerous thing because it is very powerful and motivating. And the other
几代人。但杰伊，你如何看待杰奎琳关于不同政治群体之间冲突的观点，以及她解决冲突的方法？杰奎琳指出了美国和许多其他国家目前许多人都有的一种感觉。在美国，正如你所说，这在许多情况下是政治分歧。但仇恨可以来自各种角度。它可以由种族仇恨驱动。它可以由宗教仇恨驱动。所以我认为我们必须始终非常认真地对待它，因为它是一件危险的事情，因为它非常强大且具有激励性。而另一件事。
thing to understand is one of the reasons why people are so passionately hate other groups is because it's driven from a position of morality. I actually have studied this in have several papers on it, that when people hate something, they say it's because that group or that belief system violates their sense of morality. And the moment that something violates your sense of morality, you see it through the lens of black and white, good and evil, right and wrong. And it's hard for you to listen. If you see things that way, it's hard for you to treat other people like human beings when you think that they're morally evil. But what Jacqueline's doing is almost textbook what social psychologists have found is actually really important to get past
要理解的是，人们如此强烈地仇恨其他群体的原因之一是因为它源于道德立场。我实际上研究过这一点，并有几篇关于它的论文，即当人们仇恨某事时，他们说这是因为那个群体或那个信仰体系违反了他们的道德感。而当某事违反了你的道德感的那一刻，你通过黑与白、善与恶、对与错的镜头来看待它。你很难倾听。如果你那样看待事物，当你认为别人在道德上是邪恶的时候，你很难把他们当作人类来对待。但杰奎琳正在做的事情几乎是社会心理学家发现的教科书式的，对于克服这些问题实际上非常重要。
these issues, which is that you need to realize that you can reach out to people and they're not the evil, sinister beings that you believe. Some of them might be, but often our mental images and stereotypes are way worse than reality for the entire group, and we shouldn't apply them to everybody in the group. The other thing that you need to understand is that if you approach it from a position of curiosity and you listen and reach out to other people to hear their perspectives, that turns out to be the single thing that is most powerful at putting other people at ease. Because in these types of intergroup conflicts, people, when they're interacting with someone from the other group, expect to be criticized or manipulated. And so they immediately move to the defensive and shut down.
这些问题，即你需要意识到你可以接触人们，他们并不是你所相信的那种邪恶、险恶的存在。有些人可能是，但通常我们的心理意象和刻板印象对于整个群体来说比现实要糟糕得多，我们不应该把它们应用到群体中的每个人身上。你需要理解的另一件事是，如果你从好奇心的角度出发，倾听并接触其他人以听取他们的观点，这被证明是让其他人感到轻松的最强大的事情。因为在这些类型的群体间冲突中，人们在与来自另一个群体的人互动时，期望被批评或操纵。所以他们立即转入防御并关闭。
But if you approach it from a perspective of curiosity and listening, it turns out you actually are more persuasive. They actually appreciate. the conversation more, you actually start to shatter their stereotypes as well as your own, and that becomes the foundation for having a real relationship that's built on mutual empathy and respect. And so I can't stress enough how the world would be a better place if we had many more people like Jacqueline. You know, Jacqueline's comment made me think about conversations we've had about intellectual humility. You and some colleagues recently published an interesting paper on the role of collective intellectual humility and how it might be easier as a group than
但如果你从好奇心和倾听的角度出发，事实证明你实际上更有说服力。他们实际上更欣赏对话，你实际上开始打破他们的刻板印象以及你自己的刻板印象，这成为建立在相互同理心和尊重基础上的真正关系的基础。所以我怎么强调都不为过，如果我们有更多像杰奎琳这样的人，世界会变得更美好。你知道，杰奎琳的评论让我想到了我们关于智力谦逊的对话。你和一些同事最近发表了一篇关于集体智力谦逊作用的有趣论文，以及作为一个群体，它可能比作为一个个人更容易对我们所知道或不知道的事情保持谦逊。杰伊，多告诉我一些关于这项工作的信息。
as an individual to be humble about what we know or don't know. Tell me more about this work, Jay. Yeah, a topic that really has fascinated me for the last half decade or so is intellectual humility. And what this means is essentially openness to different people, to different experiences, without getting threatened or defensive if you disagree or they challenge you. And this is often considered a virtue. It's an intellectual virtue that any of us can cultivate. Now, most of the research on this has been at the individual level, that some individuals are more intellectually humble. And it turns out people who are are less polarized, more willing to listen to people who are different than them, more willing to accept criticism of their own perspectives and accept kind of
是的，在过去五年左右的时间里，真正让我着迷的一个话题是智力谦逊。这意味着本质上是对不同的人、不同的经历保持开放，而如果你不同意或他们挑战你，你不会感到受到威胁或防御。这通常被认为是一种美德。这是一种我们任何人都可以培养的智力美德。现在，关于这一点的大多数研究都是在个人层面上的，即一些个人更具智力谦逊。事实证明，那些人极化程度较低，更愿意倾听与他们不同的人，更愿意接受对自己观点的批评并接受那种全面的事物观点。所以它被证明是一种真正的超能力。但它也在群体层面运作。所以你可以成为一个群体的一部分，并对群体中的异议和批评保持开放。有时即使在一个群体中，拥有一个智力谦逊程度低的人也可能是有用的，因为他们推动每个人去思考他们没有认真对待的事情。他们继续敲打它。这通常是举报人的心理，他们不会放弃它，因为他们认为正在发生非常糟糕的事情。
well-rounded views of things. So it turns out to be a real superpower. But it also operates at the group level. So you can be part of a group and have an openness. to dissent and criticism in the group. And sometimes even in a group, it can be useful to have someone who's low on intellectual humility because they push everybody to think about something that they're not taking seriously. And they continue to pound away at it. This is often the psychology of a whistleblower that they're not going to drop it because they think something really bad is going on.
所以他们会继续敲打它，或者向公众传达关于它的消息，因为他们对此深感担忧。所以再次，这部分是领导者的角色。去创造规范。当我每周五主持我的研究会议时，我们有一个由15到20人组成的研究团队开会，如果我谈论我们正在研究的论文或我写的东西，我分享它以获取反馈，我最后分享我的意见，因为我学到的是，一旦我成为教授，学生们就认为我很有权势。如果我说我真的很喜欢某事或不喜欢它，他们会绕着房间试图找到同意我的理由。而且他们很聪明。
And so they're going to continue to hammer at home or get the word out to the public about it because they're very deeply concerned about it. So again, this is partly the role of leaders. to create norms. And when I run my research meetings every Friday, we have a research team of 15 to 20 people who meet, if I'm talking about a paper we're working on or something that I've written and I share it for feedback, I share my opinion last because what I learned is once I became a professor, the students saw me as powerful. And if I would say I really like something or disliked it, they would go around the room trying to find reasons to agree with me. And they're smart,
所以他们能做到这一点。但当我们闭嘴并要求他们发表意见时，我们作为一个群体变得聪明多了，他们会绕着房间分享各种不同的观点，包括那些与我完全不同的观点，并捕捉到我有的盲点。在这些情况下，我们提出了更好的解决方案，更有创意的想法，我们变得更具创新性，我们的研究变得更好，变得更有影响力。你猜怎么着？那是一个每个人都喜欢的环境。所以一旦他们意识到有一种智力谦逊的氛围，它也成为了人们越来越想成为那个群体一部分的地方。所以我现在正在尝试研究的是你如何能够。
so they could do that. But we got much smarter as a group. group when I shut up and I asked them for their opinion and they would go around the room and share all kinds of different perspectives, including ones that were quite different from mine and kind of caught blind spots that I had. And in those cases, we came up with much better solutions, more creative ideas, and we became more innovative and our research became better, became more impactful. And guess what? That's an environment that everybody loves. So it also became a place that people wanted to be part of that group more and more once they realized that there was kind of this vibe of intellectual humility. So it's something I'm trying to study now is how you can
这样他们就能做到。但作为一个团队，我们变得聪明多了。当我闭嘴并征求他们的意见时，他们会轮流分享各种不同的观点，包括那些与我截然不同的观点，并指出了我的盲点。在这些情况下，我们提出了更好的解决方案和更具创意的想法，我们变得更具创新性，我们的研究也变得更好、更有影响力。你猜怎么着？那是一个人人都喜欢的环境。因此，一旦人们意识到团队中存在这种知识谦逊的氛围，这里就成了人们越来越想加入的地方。所以我现在正试图研究如何才能做到这一点。
create this in other groups because I think this is really fundamental to, A, getting a shared sense of reality, but also being creative and innovative and creating a space that people want to be a part of. Now, being part of a group is something that most of the time I think we are able to choose, but sometimes this choice is made for us. That was the case with listener Radica. I'm wondering if we could explore group think when it comes to being put in a group that you don't necessarily want to be put into, right? So there's certain identities that you want to be part of who you are. But society puts you into buckets. Society puts labels on you that maybe you don't want to have on you.
在其他群体中创造这一点，因为我认为这对于 A，获得共同的现实感，以及发挥创造力和创新精神，并创造一个人们想要参与的空间来说，是非常基础的。现在，成为一个群体的一员，我认为大多数时候我们是可以选择的，但有时这种选择是强加给我们的。听众 Radica 的情况就是这样。我想知道我们是否可以探讨一下当一个人被强行放入一个你未必想加入的群体时，群体思维会发生什么？所以，有些身份是你想要成为的自己的一部分。但社会把你放进了不同的桶里。社会给你贴上了标签，而这些标签可能并不是你想要的。
And maybe in the beginning, you sort of resist. or you fight those labels, and then eventually you're just maybe tired of fighting those labels, and you sort of just like sink into that identity. And you're like, well, I guess everyone is making me out to be this way. You know, maybe I am this way. Talk about the role of agency and choice in group membership, group participation, and group identity, Jay. The issue of agency in groups is crucially important.
也许起初你会抵制，或者反抗这些标签，但最终你可能厌倦了反抗，于是就顺从了那个身份。你会想，好吧，既然每个人都把我塑造成这样，也许我确实就是这样。Jay，谈谈代理权和选择在群体成员身份、群体参与和群体认同中的作用吧。群体中的代理权问题至关重要。
The message that I try to send to people all the time is that you should be very, very thoughtful about the groups that you join because those groups will shape you. And that was something she mentioned that once you're part of the group and people will see you that way, you start to adapt to that view. And the other way in which the group shapes you is by their values and norms, you start to internalize those. So we should be very thoughtful about the groups we join because they're going to lead us to be our best selves or worse selves.
我一直试图传达给人们的信息是，你应该非常、非常慎重地对待你加入的群体，因为这些群体会塑造你。这也是她提到的，一旦你成为群体的一员，人们就会那样看待你，你也会开始适应那种观点。群体塑造你的另一种方式是通过它们的价值观和规范，你开始内化这些东西。因此，我们应该非常慎重地对待我们加入的群体，因为它们会引导我们成为最好的自己，或者更糟的自己。
And if you try to join the groups that are going to help you attain the type of identity that you want to have and achieve the goals you want, you're going to be a lot happier and more successful in life. Now, what she's talking about is the case that happens to all of us at some point is that you're going to get put into groups. And for many of us, those groups are our age, our gender, our ethnicity, where we're born, our family lineage, because we cannot control any of those. And people stereotype us on the basis of those things. And they often do it within 100 to 200 milliseconds of seeing somebody. Wow.
如果你努力加入那些能帮助你获得你想要的身份并实现你目标的群体，你在生活中会更快乐、更成功。现在，她所谈论的是我们每个人在某个时刻都会遇到的情况，那就是你会被放入某些群体中。对于我们许多人来说，这些群体是我们的年龄、性别、种族、出生地、家族血统，因为我们无法控制这些。人们根据这些东西给我们贴上刻板印象。而且他们通常在看到某人的 100 到 200 毫秒内就做出了判断。哇。
This is what the neuroscience shows. You show somebody something within a few hundred milliseconds. They're often encoding their race, their gender, their age. And so we can't avoid that. And if people treat us differently on that basis, it's a challenge to escape it. And so this is why I strongly encourage us to, like, talk to people and be open and listen to who they are. And what identities they actually care about.
这就是神经科学所显示的。你在几百毫秒内向某人展示某样东西。他们通常已经在编码对方的种族、性别和年龄。所以我们无法避免这一点。如果人们因此而区别对待我们，想要逃避这种挑战是很难的。这就是为什么我强烈建议我们去与人交谈，保持开放的心态，倾听他们是谁，以及他们真正关心的身份是什么。
I do this exercise in groups sometimes when I'm giving you. talks. I ask people to list the 10 most important identities to them. It's a great actual conversation starter at cocktail parties or work retreats because you learn a ton about a person by what identities actually matter to them. For me, that may be a father, an author, a professor, a New Yorker now, a hockey fan, but you start to learn about what I really value and the things that I don't actually care about that aren't central to me. But when you see me, you might not see those identities. They don't pop out from the picture of me. And so it is really important that we have an open mind and talk to people because they are all of these things. The classic phrase for it is
我在做演讲时有时会进行这个练习。我让人们列出对他们最重要的 10 个身份。这实际上是鸡尾酒会或工作静修会上很好的谈话开场白，因为你可以通过一个人真正看重的身份来了解他很多。对我来说，那可能是父亲、作家、教授、现在的纽约客、曲棍球迷，但你开始了解我真正看重什么，以及那些我并不真正关心、对我来说不核心的东西。但当你看到我时，你可能看不到这些身份。它们不会从我的形象中跳出来。所以，保持开放的心态并与人交谈真的很重要，因为他们拥有所有这些身份。经典的说法是
we contain multitudes. And people don't like to be stereotyped and pigeonholed into an identity, especially one that they did not choose. And so I think we need to create a space for people to have more freedom and agency to select the identities and the groups that matter to them. And you'll see people do this. They'll signal it by wearing a hat of their favorite team or the city they're from or the country from the nation that they're born in. If that matters to them. And this is their way of sending a signal out into the world about the identities that matter to them and who they really are.
我们包含着多重性。人们不喜欢被刻板印象化，也不喜欢被归入某种身份，尤其是他们没有选择的身份。所以我认为我们需要为人们创造一个空间，让他们有更多的自由和代理权来选择对他们重要的身份和群体。你会看到人们这样做。他们会通过戴上他们最喜欢的球队、他们来自的城市或他们出生的国家的帽子来发出信号，如果这对他们很重要的话。这是他们向世界发出信号的方式，表达出对他们重要的身份以及他们真正是谁。
J. Van Baville is a psychologist at New York University with Dominic Packer. He is the author of The Power of Us, harnessing our shared identities to improve performance, increase cooperation, and promote social harmony. Jay, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me again. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
J. Van Baville 是纽约大学的心理学家，与 Dominic Packer 合作。他是《我们之力：利用我们的共同身份来提高绩效、增加合作并促进社会和谐》一书的作者。Jay，非常感谢你今天参加 Hidden Brain。非常感谢再次邀请我。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括 Annie Murphy Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Querell、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes、Andrew Chadwick 和 Nick Woodbury。Tara Boyle 是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。
You are part of an important group. Listeners of Hidden Brain. If you feel we are a part of your group identity, please help us to broaden the circle and invite more people to join our group. Please share today's conversation with a few friends, family members, or co-workers. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是重要群体的一员：Hidden Brain 的听众。如果你觉得我们是你群体认同的一部分，请帮助我们扩大圈子，邀请更多人加入我们的群体。请与几位朋友、家人或同事分享今天的对话。我是 Shankar Vedantam。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。